Hi, good morning. Good morning, everybody. Good morning to you. Good afternoon. Oh, what a wonderful day. Oh. Or a good evening for maybe some of our listeners. It could be an evening lesson. I'm just saying, depending on where you are, good, that time of day. I think most people listen to this show during the day or during the night. You know what? That's a really great question.
嗨，早上好。大家早上好。祝你早上好。下午好。哦，真是美好的一天。哦。或者对于我们的一些听众来说，可能是个美好的夜晚。这可能是个晚间节目。我只是随便说说，根据你所在的地区，祝你那个时间段过得愉快。我想大多数人都是在白天或晚上听这个节目的。你知道吗？这真是一个好问题。
And we'll get to it right after this all-new episode of Smartus. God. smart bless smart bless I will say in the blind right now my wife said to say to the guest
我们会在《Smartless》这个全新的节目播出后马上回答这个问题。天哪。智能保佑，智能保佑，我现在盲猜一下，我妻子让我对嘉宾说
that she loves them so I don't know who this is but just know half of my house loves you already oh that's nice yeah because Will talks to my wife more than I do and it's something we should get into. Hi, Willie. Let's go there now.
说她爱他们，所以我不知道这是谁，但只要知道我家里有一半人已经爱你啦。哦，那太好了。对，因为威尔跟我妻子说话比我跟我妻子说话还多，这是我们应该深入探讨的话题。嗨，威利。我们现在就聊聊这个吧。
Let's go there now. Will, why do you talk to my wife so often? You talk to her as if, I don't want to say some of these crasses, there's something going on, but it's, let's put this way. I'm married to her and I live with her and I talk to her X amount.
我们现在就聊聊这个。威尔，你为什么这么频繁地跟我妻子说话？你跟她说话的语气，我不想说得太粗俗，感觉有点什么情况，但，这么说吧。我娶了她，我和她住在一起，我和她的对话是X量。
You talk to her X plus amount. So where does that put your relationship with her? Well, let me just say this. Is there something going on? don't ask me point blank should I ask you kind of in a nuanced way I'm just saying don't ask me point blank
你跟她的对话是X加量。那这把置你和她的关系于何地呢？好吧，我只想这么说。是不是有什么情况？别开门见山地问我，我应该用那种委婉的方式问你吗？我只是说，别开门见山地问我
because you don't like to lie to me I don't like lying okay if you were to cheat on one of your friends wives would you would I be in the running or husbands
因为你不喜欢对我说谎。我也不喜欢撒谎。好吧，如果你要背着你的某个朋友偷腥他的妻子，你会——我会是候选人吗？或者丈夫？
you be yeah you have been in the running sorry you would sorry this is hypothetical about Amanda or you are the running Well, I thank you, Mr. Mark. It's a compliment to you that I love your wife. No, I do love your wife so much. I love her.
你会的，是的，你一直是候选人，抱歉，你会的，抱歉，这是关于阿曼达的假设，或者你就是候选人。好吧，谢谢你，马克先生。我爱你的妻子，这对你来说是个赞美。不，我是真的很爱你的妻子。我爱她。
She and I have a special, she and I have a special relationship as well. Are you talking to us from a gorgeous new place in New York? Not new. No, no, no. I'm just in that same place. Oh. The rental? Yes, sir.
她和我有一种特殊的，她和我也有着一种特殊的联系。你是在纽约一个豪华的新地方跟我们通话吗？不是新的。不，不，不。我只是在同一个地方。哦。那个租来的房子？是的，先生。
But did you not just get another new kind of? Maybe, yeah. I maybe did. Maybe I did that. You might actually get them. I want to stay there. Can we stay there when we come visit? But not yet. You have a place here.
但你不是刚换了另一种新地方吗？也许吧，对。我可能换了。也许我真的这么做了。你可能真的会去。我想住在那儿。我们去的时候能住在那儿吗？但还不行。你在这里有地方住。
Oh, that's right. Yeah, that's right. It's uptown, though. I'm sorry. Should we take a break? Yeah, Sean, we'll just give you a minute. Are you still on lunch? We're not back yet?
哦，对哦。对，没错。不过是在市中心。不好意思。我们该休息一下吗？对，肖恩，我们给你一分钟时间。你还在吃午饭吗？我们还没回来吗？
Snickerdoodle. Fuck, man. It's not, it's just 11.30. I know. I know I have a late lunch, so. By the way. So I just had a chicken wrap and a snickerdoodle and glass of milk. Wait, wait, but you just said you have a late lunch coming up.
思力道夫曲奇。操，老兄。现在才11点半。我知道。我知道我午饭吃得晚，所以。顺便说一句。所以我刚刚吃了一个鸡肉卷、一块思力道夫曲奇和一杯牛奶。等等，等等，但你刚才说你待会儿要吃晚午饭。
Yeah, coming up. Right. So why are you eating lunch food and tonight's dessert now? This is tying you over at 11.30. What times your lunch? 2 o'clock. Oh, my God. So you're going to eat dinner at 2.30?
对，待会儿。没错。那你为什么现在吃午餐的食物和今晚的甜点？这是为了给你11点半垫垫肚子。你几点吃午饭？两点。哦，天哪。那你两点半就要吃晚饭了吗？
Kind of like, it's like I'm going to be a weird thing because then who wants to eat at 5 or 6 when I normally eat? Are you powerlifting these days? Are you into powerlifting? What's happening? You got a big contest coming up? I would love if you just stood up and your legs, your glutes and everything were just popping.
有点像，感觉会很怪，因为等到了我通常吃饭的5点或6点，谁还想吃东西？你最近在练力量举吗？你在搞力量举重吗？怎么回事？你有什么重大比赛要参加吗？如果你站起来，你的腿、臀肌和其他部位都线条分明，我会觉得太棒了。
You know, I think I recognized that snickerdoodle from the country mart. No. Because I had one this weekend. Oh, yeah, no, they're pretty big. I do like a snickerdoodle. They're really good. What's your current favorite cookie, Willie?
你知道，我觉得我认出了那块来自乡村集市的思力道夫曲奇。没有。因为我这个周末吃过一个。哦，对，不，它们挺大的。我确实挺喜欢思力道夫曲奇的。它们真的很好吃。威利，你现在最喜欢的饼干是什么？
It's always, always, it's current and always chocolate chip cookie. Yeah, for sure. In search of the best chocolate chip cookie. It's my thing. You know, you know, I like a nice peanut. butter cookie because they're usually soft and gooey in the middle? They're often too
一直是，永远是，现在和永远都是巧克力豆饼干。对，肯定的。寻找最好吃的巧克力豆饼干。这是我的爱好。你知道，你知道的，我喜欢好吃的花生酱饼干，因为它们中间通常又软又黏？它们对我来说通常太
dry for me. You remember we were on the set of Is This Thing On Coming out or it's already out I think Oh, that's a movie. That's a movie there folks. And the craft service lady made Fresh Chocolate Chip Kicks. Remember those, Will? And Will's like, I know, I couldn't believe it. And you're like, boy, that smells
干了。还记得我们在《这玩意儿开着吗？》的片场吗？这片子快上映了，还是说已经上映了，我想。哦，那是部电影。各位，那是部电影。片场的茶歇女士做了一批新鲜的巧克力豆曲奇。还记得那些吗，威尔？威尔说：“我知道，我简直不敢相信。”而你说：“天哪，闻起来
really good. Sounds like someone on the set was honoring the fact that it was an on-camera job, Sean. Not me. I ate like five of them. You still eat like you're doing a podcast? That's right. Eat like you're doing a podcast.
真香。”听起来片场有人在向这是一份出镜工作的事实致敬，肖恩。不是我。我吃了大概五个。你吃东西的样子还是跟做播客一样？没错。吃东西的样子就像你在做播客。
That's really good. Hey, kudos to us on the podcast. We got a nice of recognition today. We just found out today, yeah, gang. We got a little golden globe now. And I want, we did. And I want to say, I want to say a lot of it has to do with our friends, Michael Terry and Bennett Barber Cow and Rob Arm Yarb.
这真的很棒。嘿，为我们在播客上的表现点赞。我们今天得到了一个很好的认可。我们今天刚发现的，对吧，各位。我们现在拿到了一个小金球奖。我想，我们确实拿到了。而且我想说，我想说很大一部分要归功于我们的朋友迈克尔·特瑞、贝内特·巴贝尔·考和罗伯·阿尔姆·亚尔布。
Those guys, these are the winds beneath our wings. Yeah, and that's why I'm happy. I'm happy for those dudes because of how hard they work and we love them so much. Thank you, guys. We love you. We don't need to hear from you. We love you. Who turns your mic on?
这些家伙，他们是我们展翅高飞的动力。对，这就是我高兴的原因。我为这些家伙感到高兴，因为他们工作有多么努力，我们太爱他们了。谢谢你们，伙计们。我们爱你们。我们不需要你们的回应。我们爱你们。谁把你的麦克风打开的？
You know what Bennett and Rob and Michael would like? They would like probably for the three of us to show up to set awards show in the event we're lucky enough to win. They'd probably like us to get up there and give a nice speech and not be stuck in New York at a play or stuck in Long Island petting a dog or something like that. I would love to, but I'm not going to be, yeah, I can't. I love to, but Robin Bennett and Michael should go in our stead.
你知道贝内特、罗伯和迈克尔会想要什么吗？如果我们足够幸运能够获奖，他们大概希望我们三个人都能出席颁奖典礼。他们大概希望我们能上台发表一段精彩的演讲，而不是被困在纽约看话剧，或者被困在长岛撸狗诸如此类的事情。我很想去，但我去不了，是的，我不能去。我很想去，但罗伯、贝内特和迈克尔应该代表我们去。
That's what I think. No, you're both coming. Wait till Amanda gets a hold of you both. I know, by the way, she already did. Yeah. Willie, maybe we fly back together just for the night. Yeah, there you go. Well, we'll talk about it.
我是这么想的。不，你们俩都得去。等着阿曼达把你们俩都抓去吧。我懂，顺便说一句，她已经这么做了。对。威利，也许我们可以一起飞回去，就待一个晚上。行，那就这样。好吧，我们再商量吧。
All right. Oh, guys, the one thing I do want to mention before we go. I want to say that we want to let you know about a new smartless media show that is celebrating the world's dumbest criminals, right? You want to let the audience know. Sean and I are well aware. This is a great little child of smartless media. What's it called? What's it called?
好了。哦，伙计们，在我们离开前，我确实想提一件事。我想说，我们想让大家知道一个全新的SmartLess传媒节目，它在歌颂世界上最笨的罪犯，对吧？你想让观众知道。肖恩和我都非常清楚。这是SmartLess传媒一个很棒的小结晶。它叫什么名字？它叫什么名字？
What's called? Okay? It's called crimeless. It's hosted by journalist Josh Dean and comedian Rory Scoville. Yeah. What do they do? What do you mean?
到底叫什么？好吧？它叫《无罪》（Crimeless）。由记者乔什·迪恩和喜剧演员罗里·斯库维尔主持。对。他们在做什么？你什么意思？
Every week, Josh tells Rory a story or two or three, you know, about some ridiculous stranger than fiction crime starring some of the most hilarious ding-dongs that you guys could possibly imagine. I want you to think of like, you know, like Cohen Brothers films, but it's real.
每周，乔什都会给罗里讲一两个或三个故事，你知道的，关于一些荒谬得离奇的犯罪，主角是你们能想象到最搞笑的笨蛋。我希望你们想一想，比如说，科恩兄弟的电影，但这是真实的。
Yeah, crimeless. It's like dumb-dums. It's like crime, dumb-dum-taking crime. It's talking like stage deaths and what, like pretend hitting in or fake drugs. Yeah, like insurance scams,
对，《无罪》。就像大笨蛋。就像犯罪，笨蛋搞砸的犯罪。就像是在假装舞台死亡，还有什么，假装被打或者假装吸毒。对，就像保险诈骗，
but done by idiots. Wow. People that don't know how to pull it off, you know. Okay, so we got new episodes of this and when are they coming out? People were like, I want to get it when does it? When would you want to hear it?
但是由白痴完成的。哇。那些根本不知道怎么收场的人，你知道的。好吧，所以我们有这个节目的新单集，它们什么时候上线？人们会问，我想看，它什么时候上线？你们什么时候想听？
You'd want to hear it on a hump day, right? That's right. Just to get you through the week. To get you through the week. Wednesday, perfect on a hump day. Yeah, all right. And wherever you get your podcast, crimeless. Okay.
你们会想在周三（“驼峰日”）听，对吧？没错。就是为了帮你度过这一周。帮你度过这一周。星期三，在周三听正合适。对，好的。无论你在哪儿收听播客，《无罪》。好的。
So, anyway. Hey, Will, you feeling good about your guest? I'm feeling really good. In fact, I want to say, speaking of which, our guest is a Golden Globe nominee, freshly minted. I think he has a couple. Yeah, that's right. Guys, we have somebody who is O'Carrant, as they say.
所以，不管怎样。嘿，威尔，你对你的嘉宾感觉怎么样？我感觉真的很好。事实上，我想说，说到这儿，我们的嘉宾是一位金球奖提名人，刚刚新鲜出炉。我想他有好几个。对，没错。伙计们，我们请到了一位他们所说的“行家”。
Oh. He's a very, he is an award-winning, celebrated actor. He says O'Carrant. I do. And my mom. You know him is A lot of people know it as Karmie From his acclaimed FX series
哦。他是一位非常有成就的、备受赞誉的演员。他说“行家”。我确实这么说。还有我妈妈。你认识他是因为——很多人认识他是因为《The Bear》里扮演的卡米，出自他广受好评的FX剧集。
Okay He's earned him an Emmy A Golden Globe Sagward for Best Actor He was just nominated for Golden Globe For Deliver Me From Nowhere You guys, it is Mr. Jeremy Allen White All right You know I will second
好吧。这让他赢得了艾美奖、金球奖、美国演员工会奖最佳男主角。他刚刚因为《Deliver Me From Nowhere》获得了金球奖提名。伙计们，这就是杰里米·艾伦·怀特先生。好吧，你知道我会附和的。
My wife's love for you Now that I see you Everybody's love for you My deep love And not only that Jeremy Before you start welcome he's also, he was also my surprise guest for a rained out Hollywood Bowl.
我妻子对你的喜爱，现在我见到你了。每个人对你的喜爱，我深深的喜爱。不仅如此，杰里米，在你开始之前，欢迎你，他也是我的惊喜嘉宾，在那个因雨取消的好莱坞露天剧场演出上。
I just found that out. I just found that out too. This is, this is, this is, this is not as good as loving up on you on the Hollywood Bowl stage, but we'll take it. We'll take it for sure. I'm so happy, I'm so happy to see you guys. I was just texting Amanda as you guys spoke about her. Oh, everybody's on with you guys.
我刚知道这件事。我也刚知道这件事。这，这，这，这不如在好莱坞露天剧场的舞台上拥抱你那么好，但我们接受了。我们绝对接受。我太高兴了，见到你们我太高兴了。就在你们谈论阿曼达的时候，我正在给她发短信。哦，你们跟每个人都在联系。
Everybody's sleeping with Amanda. Let me, Jason, let me say, and I mean. Sean, if she turns you, that's going to be it. Jason, I mean this in the most friendly way. Friendly, friendly way, and I mean this in a nun, but your wife really gets around. To texting people. To texting people.
每个人都在和阿曼达睡觉。让我，杰森，让我说，我是认真的。肖恩，如果连她都拒绝你，那可就真的没辙了。杰森，我是用最友好的方式说这话的。友好，友好的方式，我是说在一种非……但你妻子确实到处跟人交往。给别人发短信。给别人发短信。
Yeah, yeah, to let you finish. Let me finish, God, is what I said to her. You know, listen. She's a lover. She's a real lover. She's a lover. We love it. Jeremy, welcome.
对，对，让你把话说完。让我说完，天哪，这是我对她说的。你知道，听着。她是个充满爱心的人。她真的是个充满爱心的人。她是个充满爱心的人。我们很喜欢。杰里米，欢迎。
Jeremy Allen White, welcome this one of us. This is so nice. It's so nice to meet you. I'm really happy to meet you. Yeah, yeah. Congrats on the nomination. You guys have never met. Yeah, congrats on the nomination.
杰里米·艾伦·怀特，欢迎来到我们中间。这太美妙了。很高兴见到你。我真的很高兴见到你。对，对。祝贺你获得提名。你们以前从未见过面。对，祝贺你获得提名。
And Sean, you and Jerry Allen White have never met. Never met, but I'm a big fan. I'm a big fan. Oh, wait, do you meet him? You'll be in love. I'm serious. I thought the eating thing, also, I listen to the show a lot. I'm a subscriber, all of it.
肖恩，你和杰里米·艾伦·怀特从来没见过面。从来没见过，但我一直是他的超级粉丝。我是个超级粉丝。哦，等等，你见到他了吗？你会爱上他的。我是认真的。我觉得吃东西这事儿，还有，我经常听这个节目。我是个订阅用户，全听过。
I thought the eating thing was like a bit. It's all a bit. No, a lot of time. When you brought out that cookie, I couldn't believe it. Show them the milk, too. I bet you got milk right there. I got milk there. Unreal.
我以为吃东西是个段子。全都是段子。不，很多时候。当你拿出那个饼干的时候，我简直不敢相信。把牛奶也给他们看。我敢打赌你手头就有牛奶。我这儿有牛奶。太离谱了。
But Jeremy, here's one thing. First of all, Sean, enough with the Foley work. Do you need to keep it in the sleeve? You're already, like, are you trying to... You're at home. No, I'm keeping it fresh. I'm keeping it fresh.
但杰里米，有一件事。首先，肖恩，别再弄拟音了。你非得把它放在袋子里吗？你已经在，就像，你是想……你在家里。不，我在保持新鲜。我在保持新鲜。
What do you mean? In a paper bag? There's just a wax paper that's open on one end. How is that keeping it fresh from six minutes that you're taking to eat it? Can you grab a hat? What's going on with your hair? I know.
你什么意思？在一个纸袋里？那只是一张一头开口的蜡纸。这怎么能帮你吃它的这六分钟保持新鲜？你能拿个帽子吗？你头发怎么回事？我知道。
Sorry. It's like, you're going to catch on fire in a second. I'm going to buy you some product for Christmas. We're going to get Jan to send some LolaVee over. She should have an emergency crew. You know, I'll call her on Smartless Mobile to get me some LolaVee. Smart. Very smart.
抱歉。这就像，你马上就要着火了。我圣诞节要给你买点美发产品。我们要让简送点LolaVee过来。她应该派个紧急救援队。你知道的，我会用SmartLess手机打电话给她，让她给我弄点LolaVee。聪明。太聪明了。
Anyway, Jeremy, welcome. Yeah, where do we find you? I'm in Los Angeles. I just got back the other day. I was in Vancouver for a little while, and I'm in this house. Are you in an office in your house? Yeah, it's like, I try to make it an office, but it just becomes kind of storage. How do you feel about that AC unit that's sticking out of the wall?
不管怎样，杰里米，欢迎。对，我们在哪能找到你？我在洛杉矶。我前几天刚回来。我在温哥华待了一小会儿，现在在这个房子里。你是在你家的办公室里吗？对，就像，我尽量把它当成办公室，但它最后还是变成了一种储藏室。你觉得那个戳出墙外的空调感觉怎么样？
I mean, they work, right? No, I'm wearing the hat right now. It's like my house is falling apart. Nothing really works here. I got that put in recently. It doesn't work, so it's pretty chilly in here. But this is like a separate kind of room, not a guest house. There's nothing in here.
我是说，它们管用，对吧？不，我正戴着帽子呢。感觉我的房子快要散架了。这里什么都不太管用。我最近装了那个。它不管用，所以这里相当冷。但这就像是一个独立的房间，不是客房。这里面什么都没有。
The acoustics are good. Yeah, the acoustics are great. Can you give us a song? I think Robert Bennett are laughing right now. No, no. Hey, is that a chef's apron behind your left shoulder? Yeah, yeah, I've got, yeah, the chef's apron. It's like a collection of little stolen things.
这里的音响效果很好。对，音响效果很棒。你能给我们唱首歌吗？我觉得罗伯和贝内特现在在笑。不，不。嘿，你左肩膀后面是厨师围裙吗？对，对，我有，对，厨师围裙。这就像是一堆顺手牵羊的小东西的收藏。
Everybody needs a spot for them, you know. And Jeremy, you can tell us those stories into the mic. That would be great. Oh, my gosh. I like, I like gesturing. Can you guys hear me? Now we can. Okay, good, good stuff.
每个人都需要给它们找个地方，你知道的。杰里米，你可以对着麦克风给我们讲讲那些故事。那太棒了。哦，天哪。我喜欢，我喜欢手势。你们能听到我说话吗？现在能了。好的，很好，很棒。
So, Jeremy, I want to kind of get, I finally want to put the Amanda issue to bed again. But Amanda, when I knew that you were coming on to our live show, Amanda was so, Amanda Anka was so excited because she had explained to me that you and Jason are kind of newish friends in the last few months. We got set up. Yeah, yeah. We've seen each other a couple of times now.
所以，杰里米，我想了解，我终于想再次把阿曼达的事彻底解决了。但是阿曼达，当我得知你要来我们的现场演出时，阿曼达——阿曼达·安卡——非常激动，因为她跟我解释说，你和杰森在过去几个月里成了那种比较新的朋友。我们是通过别人认识的。对，对。我们现在已经见过好几次面了。
Couple times. It's very exciting. J.B., cool it. No, no, no, no. Great today, Jeremy. I feel the same. I feel the same way. that's really exciting tell me how this new found
好几次。这太令人兴奋了。J.B.，冷静点。不，不，不，不。今天感觉很棒，杰里米。我有同感。我有同感。这真的很让人兴奋。告诉我这种新建立的
I love new male friendships and how they start how did this start Jeremy I want to hear Jeremy's tale baby well it was it was Jamie who I think is friends with everybody Jamie Ms. Rahi who set us up a great great connector yeah she set us up we went to see some movies over at the house first so we had like a group hang
我喜欢新的男性友谊以及它们是如何开始的。这是怎么开始的，杰里米？我想听听杰里米的故事，宝贝。嗯，是，是杰米，我想她和每个人都是朋友，杰米·姆萨拉希把我们撮合到了一起，一个很棒很棒的牵线人。对，她把我们撮合到一起，我们先去那个房子看了几部电影，所以我们先进行了一次集体聚会
first to make sure that everything felt it wasn't awkward felt right and it was comfortable but then we got We got to go, we went to a Dodgers game, which was really, really funny, just the two of us. Always happens there. It's like an hour long ride in the car. The first one's free.
先确保一切感觉都不尴尬，感觉很对而且很舒服，然后我们去，我们去看了一场道奇队的比赛，真的非常非常有趣，就我们俩。那儿总是这样。在车里要开一个小时左右的车。第一次是免费的。
Yep, and then you sit next to me for a few hours. I've got the radio in one ear, so it's still not super pressured, you know. Yeah, it's true. And also, you don't have to fully connect with the person, so you don't have to be too. You've got something going on. Exactly. Yeah. Did you get to sit on the side of the ear that had the thing in it or not?
对，然后你在我旁边坐几个小时。我的耳朵里塞着收音机耳机，所以压力其实不是特别大，你知道的。对，确实如此。而且，你也不必跟对方完全处于连线状态，所以你不用表现得太……你有点别的事在忙。完全正确。对。你坐的是塞着耳机的那一边，还是没有的那一边？
No. No, no, no, no. He's always, how dare you, Sean? He's on the open year. I've had both. I've had both. You've had both. Sean went to the playoff, the longest baseball game playoff history. Oh, yeah. That's really exciting. I mean, yeah, I was thinking about you a lot during, oh, last year. I went last year of the World Series, but Sean went this year. Yeah, it was great. I loved it, even though it was 18 innings. A little more enthusiasm to next delivery. I really did love it. I love going. He got thrown in the deep end, though, there with that 18- inning game.
没有。不，不，不，不。他总是，你怎么敢这么说，肖恩？他在开着的那一边。两边我都坐过。两边我都坐过。肖恩去看了季后赛，棒球季后赛历史上最长的一场比赛。哦，对。那真的很令人兴奋。我是说，对，我去年经常想起你，哦，去年。我去年去了世界大赛，但肖恩今年去了。对，太棒了。我很喜欢，尽管那是18局的比赛。对下一次发言多一点热情。我真的很喜欢。我很喜欢去。不过他去那里就被扔进了深水区，经历了那场18局的比赛。
I've learned a lot. Yeah, I don't know a lot about baseball. So, Jeremy, I mean, you must have learned a lot from, like, hanging out with an older dude. Yeah. Because I know that he's always looking to, we call him Dracula, because he's always looking to suck the young blood. He said, he's always, he's like, I need, I need. I worked on my outfit for a couple of days. I need to get me some youth.
我学到了很多。对，我对棒球了解不多。所以，杰里米，我是说，你一定从跟一个老家伙闲逛中学到了很多。对。因为我知道他总是想着，我们叫他德古拉，因为他总是想吸取年轻人的鲜血。他说，他总是，他说：“我需要，我需要。”我为那天的行头筹划了好几天。我需要吸收点青春。
I need to get an injection of youth. I went for, I went for a looser cut on my gene that day. I don't know if I'm good for that. Yeah, I'm not sure. Did you get anything? I did. I picked up on a couple of things. I don't really want to reveal it here,
我需要来一针青春。那天我特意挑了一条宽松剪裁的牛仔裤。我不知道我适不适合那个。对，我不确定。你有什么收获吗？有的。我学到了一两样东西。我其实不想在这里透露，
but maybe on the next date you'll see some improvements. But did you find J.B. saying a lot of stuff like, that sounds pretty dope, dude. Yeah, that's fire. That's so fire. A couple things were suss, and Jeremy definitely had a lot of Riz that day. Wait, Jeremy, so I don't know anything about you.
但也许在下一次约会时你会看到一些改进。但是你有没有发现J.B.经常说一些“听起来挺酷的，老兄”之类的话。对，那太火辣了。太火辣了。有几件事挺可疑的，而且杰里米那天绝对有很多“魅力（Riz）”。等等，杰里米，我对你一无所知。
Where did you grow up? I grew up in Brooklyn, New York. Oh, see, now because of the show, I think Chicago. Chicago. Like, I think that's real. Yeah. No, not that the show is real, but I thought that you had a connection to Chicago. That makes sense.
你在哪里长大的？我在纽约布鲁克林长大的。哦，看吧，因为那部剧，我以为是芝加哥。芝加哥。就，我觉得那是真的。对。倒不是说这部剧是真的，但我觉得你和芝加哥有渊源。这就说得通了。
I also, I did a show before The Bear also set in Chicago. So I've been on like a Chicago set show, really my whole adult life, 18 to 45. That's what I understand. And you don't shoot the show in Chicago. Sean's always wondering what Tom Selig felt. about growing up in Hawaii. We shoot all of the bear in Chicago, yes.
而且，我在《The Bear》之前也拍过一部以芝加哥为背景的剧。所以我几乎整个成年生活都在拍以芝加哥为背景的剧，从18岁到45岁。这就是我的理解。而且你不在芝加哥拍这部剧。肖恩总是想知道汤姆·塞利格对在夏威夷长大有什么感觉。我们在芝加哥拍摄所有的《The Bear》，是的。
Tom, you're a serve? Oh, just help me. We got to get Tom on the show. We've got to get Tom Suck and dispel that. But you've got the Detroit Tiger's hat now. Was one of your parents from Detroit? So, Jeremy, did you eat the food in Chicago? Were your parents from the...
汤姆，你在发球吗？哦，帮帮我吧。我们得把汤姆请到节目上来。我们得把汤姆·萨克请来澄清这一点。但你现在戴着底特律老虎队的帽子。你的父母有一位来自底特律吗？所以，杰里米，你在芝加哥吃过东西吗？你的父母来自……
Jeremy, Jeremy, All your time in Chicago, did anybody ever bring up Glenn Ellen? No. Not once. Well, let me ask you this. Did you eat Portillo's? Yes, I love Portillo's. Isn't it great?
杰里米，杰里米，你在芝加哥呆了那么久，有人向你提起过格伦艾林吗？没有。一次也没有。好吧，那我问你这个。你吃过波蒂略（Portillo's）的快餐吗？是的，我很喜欢波蒂略。难道不是很棒吗？
Portillo's is great. Will, if you could just back the gum off the mic. Yes. The chocolate shake is huge. The chocolate shake is delicious. Yeah, it's incredible. From Bertillo's. Sean was waxing on about it before we went to Chicago.
波蒂略太棒了。威尔，如果你能把口香糖离麦克风远一点就好了。好的。巧克力奶昔超赞。巧克力奶昔太好喝了。对，太不可思议了。来自波蒂略。肖恩在我们去芝加哥之前就在大加赞赏了。
We're like, okay, okay. And then that chocolate shake arrived, and I was like, this is a real good. It's great. It's great. By the way, Jason mentioned the cake shank. cake shake, pertilla cake shake in Ozark and he didn't remember that. Yeah. No, I don't remember that either. That's wild.
我们当时想，好吧，好吧。然后那个巧克力奶昔端上来了，我就想，这真的是个好东西。太棒了。太棒了。顺便说一句，杰森提到了蛋糕奶昔。蛋糕奶昔，波蒂略的蛋糕奶昔在《黑钱胜地》里，而他却不记得了。对。不，我也不记得了。太离谱了。
Well, he was in a blackout at the time. Do you want to address these rumors? Okay, so wait. Go ahead. All right. So, Sean, you were happy. They put the cake in a shake. Have you ever asked them to do it in an IV? Like, that would really just get it straight to the bloodstream. So, so Jeremy, we're in Brooklyn.
好吧，他当时喝断片了。你想回应这些传言吗？好吧，等等。说吧。好吧，所以，肖恩，你当时很高兴。他们把蛋糕放进奶昔里。你有没有要求他们把这玩意儿做成静脉注射？那样的确能直接进入血液循环。所以，所以杰里米，我们在布鲁克林。
We're in Brooklyn. We're just learning how to read and write. We're watching cartoons. Your parents were in the field. You're when you're a kid, is that true? That's true. You read that correctly. Absolutely. And they say to you, just as you're learning how to read and write, hey, why don't you read this play?
我们在布鲁克林。我们正学着识字和写字。我们在看动画片。你的父母都在这一行。当你还是个孩子的时候，这是真的吗？是真的。你没看错。绝对是真的。他们对你说的，就在你正学着识字和写字的时候，嘿，你为什么不读读这个剧本？
Did it start that early? How did you get started? No, no. They weren't particularly pushy with all that. You know, when I was a kid, I had a lot of energy, and I think they just wanted to get rid of the energy. played sports, and that wasn't enough. And I did dance, which was kind of my first, like, getting on stage and performing sort of thing.
开始得这么早吗？你是怎么开始的？不，不。他们对这些并不是特别强求。你知道的，我小时候精力很旺盛，我想他们只是想消耗一下我的精力。我练过体育，但那还不够。我还学了舞蹈，这算是我的第一次，就像是上台表演那种。
Dance. And, yeah, so I did ballet tap and jazz for a long time in New York. That's great. Can you still do it? I can look like I can do it. I mean, tap was my favorite. And I can shuffle a little bit. But, no, it's been a long time.
舞蹈。而且，是的，所以我很长一段时间在纽约练习芭蕾、踢踏舞和爵士舞。太棒了。你现在还会跳吗？我看起来像是会跳的样子。我是说，踢踏舞是我的最爱。我还能稍微跳一点交叉步。但是，不，那已经是很久以前的事了。
But when you're at a party and there's a dance floor, like, to me, that's, it looks like a quick. Pitt, like, watch out, don't get anywhere near it. Like, I've got an allergy to it. Are you thinking like, okay, all right, there's my plan for a little bit later on. Like, are you excited to dance? There was a time, like in my mid-20s, I had in L.A. and New York, like, a dance spot for almost every night of the week. Oh, my God.
但当你在派对上，有个舞池的时候，对我和我来说，那看起来就像是个危险陷阱。比如，小心，千万别靠近。比如，我对它过敏。你会想，好吧，好吧，这是我一会儿的计划吗？比如，你期待跳舞吗？曾几何时，比如在我25岁左右的时候，我在洛杉矶和纽约，几乎一周的每一天都有一个跳舞的地方。哦，天哪。
No way. Yeah. Not like ballroom dancing, but, like, there was like a dance yourself clean night. There was a spot in Chinatown. There was a spot in Chinatown. There's a level of confidence to your dancing that it actually is something that you look forward to and this is a bit of a, it's a little bit of a flex
真的假的？对。不是那种交际舞，而是那种有像“跳舞洗刷自我（Dance Yourself Clean）”之夜的地方。唐人街有个地方。唐人街有个地方。你的舞蹈有一种自信，这实际上是你所期待的事情，这有点像是一种炫耀
when you like you've, I don't want to put you on the spot but words in your mouth but it's not something you avoid let's put it that way. It's not something I avoid. I like to dance. God, I wish I was like to. Yeah, I'll say it. Hollywood is going to go nuts for you because you're straight
当你喜欢的时候，我不想把你架在火上烤，或者把话塞进你嘴里，但这并不是你刻意回避的事情，我们这么说吧。这并不是我刻意回避的事情。我喜欢跳舞。天哪，我希望我也能喜欢。是的，我会这么说的。好莱坞会为你疯狂的，因为你是直男
and you can dance. They're going to put you in so many. Yeah, wait until Hollywood gets a notice of you. You're going to do great. No, Matt. Get on out here. No, I met like, what's that Ryan Gosting movie? Oh, La La Land.
而且你会跳舞。他们会把你安排进那么多的……是的，等着好莱坞注意到你吧。你会干得很棒的。不，マット（Mat）。来这儿吧。不，我遇到过，那部瑞恩·高斯林的电影叫什么？哦，《爱乐之城》。
Yeah, La Land. Jeremy, let's say it's a Tuesday night and you know of a place in New York, you're like, all right, I'm going to go out. There's like a 70s dance thing and you've got your new buddy, J.B., and it's late for him because it's 9 o'clock and he's a little nervous about how late it is.
对，《爱乐之城》。杰里米，假设现在是周二晚上，你知道纽约有个地方，你会想，好吧，我要出去。那儿有个70年代的舞蹈派对，你带着你的新死党J.B.，这对他来说已经很晚了，因为现在是9点钟，他有点担心时间太晚了。
He wants to go to the disco. What would... I would... Could you teach him how to dance, do you think? Please. Yeah, I mean, there was a place. Sway in New York, they have the Smith's Night. And I think you could do that, right?
他想去迪斯科舞厅。你会……我……你能教他怎么跳舞吗？你觉得呢？求你了。我是说，有个地方。纽约的Sway酒吧，他们有史密斯乐队（The Smiths）之夜之夜。我想你能跳那个，对吧？
I love that. Can you dance to the Smith? Yeah, it's like Smith's cure, like, you know, you can figure it out, yeah. Wait, how old are you? Jason, you shut your mouth, how can you say, I go about things the wrong way. So I can just sort of just rock and sway as opposed to boogie. I'm not that much, but you've got boogie moves, yeah? I mean, I feel like the more we talk about is someone's really going to try to get me to
我太喜欢了。你能随着史密斯乐队的歌跳舞吗？对，就像史密斯、治疗乐队（The Cure）那样，你知道的，你能搞定的，对吧？等等，你多大？杰森，闭上你的嘴，你怎么能说我做事的方式不对呢？所以我可以只是摇晃和摆动，而不是疯狂摇摆。我没那么大年纪，但你确实有摇摆舞步，对吧？我是说，我觉得我们越是谈论这个，就越是会有人真的试图让我……
But you've got Boneymoot. Man, I was looking for something to put on a hat. I can dance, yes. I've got some rhythm. I can dance. I can dance.
但你确实有骨气。老兄，我一直在找东西戴在帽子上。我会跳舞，是的。我有点节奏感。我会跳舞。我会跳舞。
Yeah. I'm very jealous. And I'm sure you could do it, Jason. Yes. So you're singing and dancing as a kid, which you've continued into into adulthood. And then what happened? You start doing theater?
对。我非常嫉妒。我确信你也能做到，杰森。所以你从小又唱又跳，一直持续到成年。然后发生了什么？你开始演话剧了？
Yeah, so I joined the, I did, I joined kind of a new school in middle school in seventh grade. and I joined the dance program naturally because I'd been doing that for a while, but I didn't find the class took dance seriously enough. Oh, boy. I didn't feel the teacher took it seriously enough.
对，所以我加入了，我加入了，我在初中七年级时转到了一所新学校。我自然而然地加入了舞蹈项目，因为我之前已经跳了很长时间，但我发现那个班对舞蹈不够认真。哦，天哪。我觉得老师对舞蹈不够认真。
Wow. And so I switched to the drama program. Did you have leg warmers on at the time you were in this level of disdain? Yeah, I was stretching. I had the warmers on. I did the whole thing, and I just did think they were taking it. He was a big boat in a collar. My belly was showing.
哇。所以我转到了戏剧项目。你当时表现出这种不屑一顾的时候，身上穿着腿套吗？对，我在拉伸。我穿着腿套。我把那一套全套都穿上了，而且我就是觉得他们不够认真。他穿着一件大翻领的衣服。我的肚子都露出来了。
Yeah, and you're like, these fucking people. I just didn't think they took it seriously. Truly, though, I mean, it sounds ridiculous. But at the time, I was like, this doesn't feel, you know, it's like they're not taking seriously enough. And I found a drama teacher at this school, John McAnney, who took things so seriously. And some of my best friends were in this school already in this class.
对，而你的表情就像：这帮狗屎。我只是觉得他们不够认真。不过说实话，我是说，听起来很荒谬。但当时我觉得，这感觉不对，你知道的，就像他们不够认真一样。我在那所学校里找到了一位戏剧老师，约翰·麦卡尼（John McAnney），他对事情极其认真。我的一些好朋友当时已经在学校的这个班里了。
And, yeah, my first time acting was like in a little black box at this school in Brooklyn, this middle school in Park Slope. Wow. And I remember, yeah, getting on it. on that stage for the first time and really feeling like a sense of, I don't know, like focus or presence or something that I hadn't been able to find, like a real ease.
而且，是的，我第一次演戏是在布鲁克林这所学校的一个小黑匣子剧场里，帕克坡的这所初中。哇。我记得，是的，第一次踏上那个舞台，真的感觉到了一种，我不知道，就像专注力或在场感之类的东西，是我以前从来没能找到的，一种真正的松弛感。
Did you feel anything from the audience? Was it a comedy? Did you get a laugh or what drama? Did you feel that you'd move them? It was, no, funnily enough, it was like an exercise where we had to have two actors where a monologue was being performed, but there were two actors on stage.
你从观众那里感受到什么了吗？那是部喜剧吗？你博得笑声了吗，还是悲剧？你觉得自己打动他们了吗？那是，不，有趣的是，那是一个练习，我们需要有两个演员，其中一个人在表演独白，但舞台上有两个演员。
And I was the actor not speaking. A dream job. And, yeah. But it was amazing to feel like if you could feel focused on the person across from you and really be listening. Like I felt attention on me, even in silence, just kind of like focusing on somebody else. And I felt like, I don't know, my mind wasn't racing. I wasn't, like, there is something, and still that's why I like acting so much. Like I find I'm so ahead of myself a lot of the time or anxious or, you know, and then when I'm on set or a performance,
而我是那个不说话的演员。梦想的工作。而且，是的。但那种感觉真的很奇妙，如果你能专注于你对面的人，真正地去倾听。就像我能感觉到别人把注意力放在我身上，哪怕是在沉默中，只是那种专注于另一个人。我觉得，我不知道，我的大脑没有飞速运转。我没有，就像，有些东西，这就是为什么我到现在还这么喜欢演戏。我发现我很多时候都思虑过多，或者很焦虑，你知道的，然后当我进入片场或者进行表演时，
performing, there's like a real like simplicity or focus or something happens that's really nice. Yeah, do you have like a little bit of ADD or something like that? For sure. Yeah, same. And then when I'm doing this, I'm working on this play right now and it's a monologue, it's 40 pages.
在表演的时候，有一种真正的简单、专注或者某种美妙的事情发生。是的，你有点注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADD）或者类似的毛病吗？肯定的。对，我也是。然后当我做这个的时候，我正在排练这部话剧，这是一段独白，有40页。
And I find that when I have the one thing like you're saying, to focus on, it actually calms my brain a little bit. Everything else gets kind of quiet. Yeah, and there's something really nice about that. Oh, Sean, you would describe yourself, Sean, as having a little bit of ADD? Did you say 40? pages? It's a one-man show. It's another way to put a one-man show.
我发现当我有了像你说的这种专注点时，它实际上会让我的大脑平静一点。其他的一切都变得安静下来了。对，那种感觉真的很棒。哦，肖恩，你会把自己形容为有点ADD的人吗？你刚才说40页？这是一部独白剧。这是对单人秀的另一种说法。
He's learning a... Wow. I can't believe they're bringing puppetry of the penis back. That's so exciting. Where is the show? At Studio C-View, which is John Krasinski just did his show there last summer, I think. Which is great. Yeah. When does it go up? January 31st, it opens.
他在背一本……哇。我简直不敢相信他们要把《阴茎木偶戏》（Puppetry of the Penis）搬回来。太令人兴奋了。演出在哪里？在C景工作室（Studio C-View），约翰·卡拉辛斯基去年夏天刚刚在那里演了他的剧，我想。太棒了。什么时候上映？1月31日开幕。
I can't make that. That's exciting. I know. Oh, no. Well, I think that's previews start January 30th. Anyway, but I know what you mean about you being able to focus it gives you something to focus on that you can put all your energy towards as opposed to feeling very like scattered
我赶不上那个。那太令人兴奋了。我知道。哦，不。好吧，我想那是1月30日开始预演。不管怎样，但我明白你的意思，关于你能专注于某事，它能给你一个焦点，让你把所有的精力都倾注进去，而不是感觉思绪非常分散。
that's where my brain works I feel very scattered and same and we will be right back and now back to the show so you find this thing and you're like I'm locked in I feel locked this is something that I respond to and I like
这就是我大脑运作的方式，我觉得非常分散，我也是，我们马上回来，现在回到节目中。所以你发现了这个东西，然后你想：我进入状态了，我觉得自己完全投入了，这是我能产生共鸣并喜欢的东西
and then you go you start auditioning for professional roles. Yeah, this teacher who was so serious. I mean, he had us doing, we did Macbeth and 12th night as 12-year-olds, back-to-back. He was just so serious as a teacher. Keep his life for the kids.
然后你去开始试镜专业角色。对，这位老师非常严肃。我是说，他让我们排练，我们作为12岁的孩子排练了《麦克白》和《第十二夜》，一部接一部。他作为老师实在是太严厉了。为孩子们奉献了一生。
How does his 12-year-old learn Shakespeare? He would wake up, he lived near the school, and he would come to school with, like, nosebleeds when we were doing dress for her. Like, he was so, like, in it and focused, and, you know, he really... He was in something. He cared very much about it. And he would send me out on, like, he would go to Backstage, which is, like, you know, where you could do open casting calls.
12岁的孩子怎么学莎士比亚？他会醒来，他住在学校附近，当我们在进行服装彩排时，他会流着鼻血来到学校。就像，他太投入、太专注了，你知道，他真的很……他完全沉浸其中。他非常关心这件事。他会把我派去，就像，他会去“后台网”（Backstage），那是你可以参加公开招募的地方。
And I got my first couple jobs, yeah, going on the open castles. Oh, that's great. No way, that's so rad. What was the first one? Do you remember? I did this off, off, off Broadway play called The Present. And that was kind of my first job. I think we got paid. I hope we got paid.
我得到了我的前几份工作，是的，通过参加公开试镜。哦，太棒了。不会吧，太酷了。第一份工作是什么？你还记得吗？我演了一部非百老汇的非主流舞台剧，叫《礼物》（The Present）。那算是我第一份工作。我想我们拿到了报酬。我希望我们拿到了报酬。
But yeah, that was my first job. It was like on the Upper West Side. And you were in middle school? That was in middle school. Wow. And then I think I got a commercial maybe. And then my first movie, they came to do an open casting call at the school. And a great casting director, Cindy Tolan, was casting that film.
但是的，那是我的第一份工作。就像在上西区。那时你在上初中？那是初中。哇。然后我想我可能拍了个广告。接着是我的第一部电影，他们来学校进行公开试镜。一位非常优秀的选角导演辛蒂·托兰（Cindy Tolan）负责那部电影的选角。
And she told me, you know, we don't know if this movie is ever going to come together. It'll take a long time. It was a very small budget film. But she said, you know, you're good at this and you should really audition more. And so she wrote me a really great letter to take around to agents and stuff. So I ended up getting an agent.
她告诉我，你知道，我们不知道这部电影是否能拍成。这需要很长时间。那是一部预算很小的电影。但她说，你知道的，你很擅长这个，你真的应该多去试镜。所以她给我写了一封非常棒的信，让我可以拿着去找经纪人什么的。所以我最后签了一个经纪人。
That's great. Wow. Yeah, thank you, Cindy Tolan. Now, was singing ever a part of this? I forgot. No. It was not. No, no.
太棒了。哇。是的，谢谢你，辛蒂·托兰。那么，唱歌曾经是其中的一部分吗？我忘了。没有。并不是。不，不。
Just dance, yeah. So then musical theater was never really a draw or a temptation. But how about now? Now that you've taught yourself how to sing. I mean, your performance is so mind-blowing in the Springsteen thing. I don't want to embarrass you. We don't have to talk about it because I'm sure you're tired of talking about it.
只有舞蹈，对。所以音乐剧从来都不是真正的吸引力或诱惑。但现在呢？既然你已经自学了唱歌。我是说，你在布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀传记片里的表现简直令人震撼。我不想让你尴尬。我们不必谈论这个，因为我确信你已经厌倦了谈论它。
But it's just effing incredible. And the fact that you learn how to sing in someone else's voice on top of that and learned how to play guitar, I think, too. You get to learn how to play guitar for this role. To take on that. At least look like I could handle it. Yeah. Wow.
但它真的是牛逼惨了。最重要的是，你还在别人的声音里学会了唱歌，除此之外还学会了弹吉他，我想也是。为了这个角色，你得学会弹吉他。来承担这一切。至少看起来我能应付得来。哇。
Incredible. Huge, huge nards. taken that on and doing such a great job. Jason was going on and on about how, I'm so sorry, I haven't seen it yet, but it's on my list, I swear. But Jason was just raving about your performance and as everybody else.
太不可思议了。胆子真大，真大。敢于接下这个任务并且做得这么好。杰森一直在喋喋不休地说着，我很抱歉，我还没看过，但它在我的清单上，我发誓。但杰森对你的表演赞不绝口，其他人也是如此。
He's incredible. I can't wait to see it. So now that you've got the singing and the dancing, and I don't know if you need the guitar part for a musical theater, but like, do you think about doing like a musical on Broadway or something? Like a la la la la. I don't know. I mean, it's never been, I mean, I have no
他太不可思议了。我迫不及待想看了。既然你已经会唱歌跳舞了，我不知道你演音乐剧是否需要吉他部分，但是，比如说，你有没有想过在百老汇演音乐剧之类的？比如像《啦啦啦啦》（La La Land）那种。我不知道。我是说，从来没有，我是说，我没有
issue and I've like enjoyed musical theater but it's like seeing it, but it's never been, like in high school, I went to a performing arts school and I would do theater, but it was usually kind of straight plays and stuff. And, yeah, I don't know. I've never had that draw to be in it.
任何问题，而且我也很享受音乐剧，比如看演出，但从来没有，就像在高中时，我去了一所表演艺术学校，我会演戏剧，但通常都是那种正剧之类的。而且，我不知道。我从来没有那种去参演的冲动。
I've been a fan of it. But you wouldn't run if somebody brought you something. Let's say like the new Hamilton kind of thing. Or like as Sean would mention for 50 times, La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La. Jesus. Guys, why you marry that movie? La La Land 2, I would definitely be interested in doing.
我是它的粉丝。但如果有人拿给你一个项目，你也不会逃跑。比方说像新的《汉密尔顿》那种。或者像肖恩会重复50遍的那样，啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦。天哪。伙计们，你们为什么那么迷恋那部电影？《爱乐之城2》，我绝对有兴趣去拍。
How about the Christmas sequel, Fala La Land? Fala Land. J.B, that's really good. Thanks, guys. That is nice. Wait, so are you, do you play an instrument now? Like, do you play anything piano or anything else? No, I mean, I never really learned how to play anything.
圣诞续集《法拉啦之城》（Fala La Land）怎么样？法拉之城。J.B.，这太妙了。谢谢你们，伙计们。这确实不错。等等，所以你现在会乐器吗？比如，你会弹钢琴或其他什么吗？不，我是说，我从来没真正学会弹任何东西。
And I remember, you know, I had about six months to learn guitar, which, you know, isn't enough time, really, to learn how to play the guitar. But I got together with a really great teacher and we just learned the couple songs that I needed to learn, but it makes it very hard for me to learn or to play other things now because I didn't learn in a traditional way. So even if I try to learn something else, I kind of end up playing Mansion on a Hill or something.
我记得，你知道的，我有大约六个月的时间来学吉他，你知道的，这其实根本不够时间学会弹吉他。但我跟一位非常棒的老师在一起，我们只是学会了我需要弹的那几首歌，但这导致我很难再去学习或弹奏其他东西，因为我不是用传统方式学习的。所以即使我试图学点别的，我最后也会弹成《山顶上的豪宅》（Mansion on a Hill）或者别的什么。
Like it doesn't translate it. You still have fallaces on the tips of your fingers? Yeah, they're still a little rough. Really? Because it hurts, right? And I still pick up, I mean, you know, Bruce Springsteen, he was so involved in kind of the process of making the movie
就像它转换不过来。你手指头上现在还有老茧吗？对，它们还是有点粗糙。真的吗？因为那很疼吧？我还是会拿起来，我是说，你知道的，布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀，他非常投入到电影的制作过程中
and really lovely and supportive all the way through but yeah you seem to really love it yeah yeah he's seen it a lot but he bought me a 1955 Gibson J200 which is the same model
而且一路上都非常可爱和支持，但是，是的，你似乎真的很喜欢它。对，对，他看过很多次。但他送了我一把1955年的吉布森J-200（Gibson J-200），那是同一个型号
and almost year he he recorded it on 1954 but after our first meeting he sent me this guitar which is very beautiful guitar and so I do pick it up every once in a while just because I feel guilty letting it sit and collect dust. Is it there in the office and you're in your
而且几乎是他录音时用的年份，那是1954年的，但在我们第一次见面后，他寄给我这把吉他，这是一把非常漂亮的吉他，所以我确实偶尔会拿起来弹弹，纯粹是因为觉得让它闲置积灰有点内疚。它就在你的办公室里吗，你在你的
you know what? As I said, my house is falling apart when that rain was happening. I was nervous that there would be some moisture in here. So it's actually under my bed at this moment and where it's really safe. That's smart. You know, I bought a Christmas tree here yesterday in New York and I dragged it back to my place here we decorated yesterday. Did somebody film it?
你知道吗？正如我所说，下雨的时候我的房子都快塌了。我当时很担心里面会有湿气。所以它现在其实在我的床底下，非常安全。真聪明。你知道的，我昨天在纽约买了一棵圣诞树，然后把它拖回了我这里，我们昨天还把它装饰好了。有人把它拍下来了吗？
And I thought, you know, yeah, obviously I film everything. And I thought about I thought about if I ever wanted to I'd have a Christmas tree stand down on Spring Street, you know, just this season and I'd call spruce of Spring Street. You know what I mean? Nice.
我想着，你知道的，对啊，我显然什么都拍。我当时就在想，如果我想的话，我可以在斯普林街摆一个圣诞树摊，你知道的，就这个季节，然后我打算把它叫作“斯普林街的云杉”。你知道我的意思吗？不错。
Bravo. That was worth it. That was worth it. Wait, we'll tighten it up. So, Jeremy, so what was the first thing then after all that theater experience that got you out to the West Coast? I got a job. I was very lucky right out of high school.
太棒了。这太值得了。这太值得了。等等，我们把它收紧点。所以，杰里米，经历了那么多戏剧表演之后，是什么让你来到了西海岸？我找到了一份工作。我高中刚毕业就很幸运。
I got a job on a TV show called Shameless. Oh, yes, of course. Of course you're on that. Yeah, fantastic. You were on for like a decade. Am I right about that? More. I was, man, I was 18 when we did the pilot,
我在一部叫作《无耻之徒》的电视剧里找到了一份工作。哦，对，当然。你当然演过那个。太棒了。你演了大约十年，我没记错吧？更久。真的，拍试播集时我18岁，
and I was 30 when we finished. Wow. What takes you through a lot. And that was the first gig, or the first big gig? I did, yeah. I did some film and like every law and order and stuff like that when I was in New York.
拍完时我30岁。哇。这经历了很多事。那是你的第一份工作，还是第一份大工作？是的，我拍过。在纽约时，我拍过一些电影，还演过像《法律与秩序》之类的好多剧。
But yeah, Shameless brought me to Los Angeles. and kept me in Los Angeles. Yeah, that's so cool. That's incredible. 18 to 30. Yeah, it just doesn't happen. Right. So you're inside that cocoon, that comfortable cocoon of a series
不过，是的，《无耻之徒》把我带到了洛杉矶，并把我留在了洛杉矶。太酷了。真是不可思议。18岁到30岁。是的，这种事真的很少发生。对。所以你一直呆在那个茧里，一个系列带来的舒适的茧中，
through your whole launch, right? And you've got great notices through that and you're meeting everybody and you're getting other opportunities during the hiatuses in between each season a little bit? Yeah, I try to do something, you know. Yeah, I try to do something each hiatus we shot about five months and yeah if I was lucky I'd get a movie or or I did another like an
贯穿了你的整个事业起步期，对吧？你在其中获得了很棒的评价，见到了所有人，并且在每一季之间的间歇期里也得到了一些其他机会吗？对，我尽量做点什么，你知道的。对，我尽量在每个间歇期都做点什么，我们大约拍摄五个月，如果运气好的话，我会接拍一部电影，或者我曾经演过另一个像
Amazon sort of series one time but but yeah I mean I didn't have to I mean I was so happy and felt so lucky to have that kind of like I don't know that consistency and kind of continuity in my life especially in my 20s especially as an actor to kind of just have have some place you knew where you were going to be for four months every year five months every year. Did you have time to also have a life? I mean, that takes you all the way through your 20s. Like, that's a time when you really want to have fun.
亚马逊那样的剧集，但是，是的，我的意思是，我其实不必——我是说，我感到非常高兴，觉得自己太幸运了，能拥有那种——我不知道，那种生活中的稳定感和延续性，尤其是在我二十多岁的时候，特别是作为一个演员，能够有那么一个地方，让你每年有四个月、五个月的时间知道自己要去哪里。你当时有时间也去过生活吗？我的意思是，那可是你整个二十多岁的时光。就像，那是你真的很想去玩乐的时期。
Did you find time to do all that stuff too? Yeah, definitely found time for all that stuff. Yeah, I mean, I bounced around. Like, we shot the show here, and I got a place back home in New York when I was like 22, and so I'd kind of, like, split my time between L.A. and New York. And then, yeah, I mean, by the time we finished the show, I had, you know, You know, I had my two daughters. A lot of life happened.
你当时也找到了时间去做所有那些事情吗？对，我绝对找到了时间做所有那些事情。是的，我的意思是我到处跑。比如，我们在那里拍剧，当我大约22岁的时候，我在老家纽约弄了个住处，所以我就有点像是在洛杉矶和纽约之间分配时间。然后，是的，到我们拍完这部剧的时候，我，你知道的，我有了两个女儿。经历了好多生活。
Wow, you have two kids? Yes, he and Dolly. Yeah, yeah, two daughters, yeah. Wow. How old are that? Dolly turns five on Friday, and Esi turned seven in October. I mean, you still look like you're 30, which is crazy. I know. Well, how old were, I mean, I was 27.
哇，你有两个孩子？对，Esi和Dolly。对，对，两个女儿，对。哇。多大了？Dolly周五满五岁，Esi在十月满七岁。我的天，你看上去还是像30岁一样，这太疯狂了。我知道。好吧，你当时多大，我是说，我27岁。
Yeah, when Ezzie was born. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. In that time, did you ever cross-over? I think he wrote on your show, Mike O'Malley. Didn't he right now? Oh, my gosh, of course.
对，Esi出生的时候。对。哇。在那期间，你们有过交集吗？我记得他好像在你的剧里写过剧本，迈克·奥马利。他不是写过吗？哦，天哪，当然。
Yeah. He's a good friend of all of ours. Yeah. Mike was a writer on Shameless? He was on Glee at the same time, too, which was like such a huge show. And I was like, oh, wow, you're such a big actor and you're writing on our show.
对。他是我们所有人的好朋友。对。迈克是《无耻之徒》的编剧？他当时也同时在拍《欢乐合唱团》，那可是一部超级火的剧。当时我想，哦，哇，你这么大牌的演员，居然还在我们剧组写剧本。
Mike's had a really cool career. Like, really cool career. Right? Mike's had a really cool career so far. Yeah, I love that guy. Has he done acting, stand up, writing, producing. He's done it all. He's such a talented guy, such a talented writer.
迈克的职业生涯真的很酷。真的是超级酷的职业生涯。对吧？迈克到目前为止的职业生涯真的很酷。对，我超喜欢那家伙。他做过演员、单口喜剧演员、编剧、制片人。他什么都做过。他是个多才多艺的人，是个极具才华的编剧。
And we all, I mean, he's such a great old, old friend of mine. He's not that old, Will. No. All right. He's just the best. We love you, Mike. He's a sweetheart. He is a sweetheart.
而且我们都——我是说，他是我非常好、非常多年的老朋友。他没那么老，威尔。不。好吧。他就是最棒的。我们爱你，迈克。他是个大好人。他确实是个大好人。
So that takes you through to your third. All of a sudden, so now you're 30, and it's weird coming off a show when you've been on it for a long time, right? That's a weird. Yeah, did you think, like, okay, it's all going to be downhill from here? 100%.
所以这让你一直拍到了第三季。突然之间，你现在30岁了，当你在一部剧里演了很长时间后抽身出来，这种感觉很奇怪，对吧？那是一种很奇怪的。对，你当时有没有想过，比如，好吧，从这里开始一切都会走下坡路了？百分之百。
I felt totally, I mean, you know, I... Leave the cocoon. Yeah, I remember, I mean, I really did. We did ADR for the last, for whatever, the last episode of the 11th season of Shameless. I was at Warner Brothers. So, Tracy, that's where you re-recorded some dialogue if it didn't, if it wasn't recorded well on the day.
我完全有这种感觉，我是说，你知道的，我……离开那个舒适圈。对，我记得，我真的有那种感觉。我们在华纳兄弟给《无耻之徒》最后一季，无论是哪一集，做了后期对白配音。我在华纳兄弟。所以，崔西，那就是如果你当天的台词录得不好，重新录音的地方。
It's sort of a finishing process. There you go. There you go. Yeah, it means kind of the end. It's your last connection often with the thing. And I finished that and I was driving home from Warner Brothers and had a full, like, panic. I had to pull over, my arms went, I was so...
这有点像是一个收尾的过程。就是这样。就是这样。对，这意味着某种结束。这往往是你与这事物的最后联系。我做完这些，从华纳兄弟开车回家，直接开始恐慌。我不得不把车停在路边，我的双臂都……我当时太……
Wow, really? Wow. Yeah, I mean, it had just been such a comfort. And, you know, I was with those actors for 11 years, and, I mean, they're like my family, brothers and sisters. Like, I got so close with everybody, and I felt like I was saying goodbye to not only kind of, like, my work environment and that sort of, like, comfort and security, but also saying goodbye to these people
哇，真的吗？哇。对，我的意思是，那一直是一种慰藉。而且，你知道的，我和那些演员一起度过了11年，我的意思是，他们就像我的家人、兄弟姐妹一样。我跟所有人都变得非常亲密，我觉得我不仅是在告别我的工作环境以及那种舒适感和安全感，也是在告别这些
who had been so solid for me for so long. And yeah, I just didn't know what was next. And I had a very hard time. How did you, what was the thing that was most helpful that got you to, because I know that panic well. Yeah. What do you, did you lean on a friend? Did you go into therapy?
陪伴了我这么久、一直给我坚实支持的人们。是的，我只是不知道接下来会怎样。我当时非常难熬。你是怎么，是什么最帮到你走出来的，因为我很清楚那种恐慌。对。你靠的是什么，你会向朋友倾诉吗？你会去做心理治疗吗？
I mean, I'm just citing all the things that I get, friends, therapy. I partied. I like, you know, just everything. Yeah. What? I certainly, yeah, was in therapy. and was talking about her a lot. But I was also very lucky, like, so, I mean, you know,
我是说，我只是在列举我能想到的所有事情，朋友，心理治疗。我当时到处狂欢。我就是，你知道的，什么都试了。对。什么？我当然，对，做过心理治疗，也经常提起她。但我也非常幸运，所以，我的意思是，你知道的，
there's so much luck involved in all of this thing. But, you know, I spoke to Chris Storer, who created The Bear. He produced this movie I did, The Rental, like, after season nine of Shameless. And Chris, I didn't see him on set a lot. He was kind of back and forth, but he comes up to me on kind of the last day. and Chris goes Hey what do you think you're going to be doing in three years And I don't really know
这里面有很多运气的成分。但是，你知道的，我和《熊家餐馆》的创作者克里斯·斯托勒聊过。在《无耻之徒》第九季之后，他监制了我拍的一部电影《租赁惊魂》。克里斯，我当时在片场不常看到他。他总是来来去去的，但在差不多最后一天的时候，他朝我走来，
Like you know I think I got a couple more years of shameless And he goes all right buddy I'm going to call you in three years And he walked away And I was like what a fucking jerk Like what a Hollywood jerk Like there's no way I'm ever going to hear from that guy Ever again
克里斯说：“嘿，你觉得三年后你在干什么？”我其实也不知道。
And he called me Just as we were wrapping up season 11 And said I have to show the bear You know, I'd really like you to do it But I was hesitant at first Because it was, you know, I love Chicago But based in Chicago again And there was some kind of like family dynamics
就像你知道的，我觉得我还能再拍几年《无耻之徒》。然后他说：“好吧，老兄，三年后我给你打电话。”然后他就走开了。我当时想：这混蛋在搞什么鬼？简直是个好莱坞混蛋。我绝不可能再听到这家伙的任何消息了。
That seemed like similar upon first read to me And so I just wasn't sure I'd do it yet But I just kept reading the script for the bear and the pilot And it was so great And I got to the point where I was just like You know, it's not my business to pass I have no right to pass on something this this good.
结果就在我们杀青第11季的时候，他真的打电话给我，说：“我有一部剧叫《熊家餐馆》，你知道的，我真的很希望你来演。”但我一开始有点犹豫，因为，你知道的，我热爱芝加哥，但又是以芝加哥为背景，而且其中有一些家庭动态，
So even though I was anxious about the future and all this stuff, I was shooting the pilot for the bear probably two months after that panic attack. I knew I was going somewhere. So I was able to kind of throw myself into something else. Yet it was still just a pilot, right?
我初读剧本时觉得似曾相识。所以我一开始还不确定要不要接。但我一直不断地阅读《熊家餐馆》的剧本和试播集，它实在是太棒了。最后我甚至觉得：你知道的，拒绝不是我的风格，我没有权利拒绝这么好的作品。
So you had to sweat. Totally. The delivery of that, the network reading it or sorry, watching it and giving it a pickup, right? FX, I believe still is one of the, I don't think it's like
所以尽管我对未来感到焦虑以及诸如此类的事情，但在那次恐慌发作大约两个月后，我还是去拍了《熊家餐馆》的试播集。我知道我要去某个地方了。所以我能够把精力投入到别的事情中去。然而它仍然只是个试播集，对吧？
this is kind of inside baseballer, but it's like you know, I think a lot of shows will go straight to series these days with streaming but FX continues to sort of, they shoot a pilot everybody watches it, they see what it looks like, they take a look at, you know,
所以你还是得提心吊胆。完全是的。成片的效果、电视网的审阅，或者抱歉，是观看并决定预订它，对吧？FX，我深信它依然是其中一个——我不认为这算是什么业内秘辛，但就像是，你知道的，我觉得现在很多剧集在流媒体时代会直接整季预订，但FX依然会这样做，他们拍摄试播集，每个人都看，看看效果如何，审视一下，你知道的，
what you want to do with the first season. Well, they make pretty good shows over there, so they're they do. No, no, wonderful. We have a question about staying in Chicago, so those 11 seasons you did of Shameless and then the bear, Do you find a new place to stay every time you go, or do you have a hub that you stay at? What a great question, Sean?
你对第一季有什么构想。好吧，他们在那里制作的剧集都相当不错，所以他们确实——不，不，太棒了。我们有个关于留在芝加哥的问题，你在《无耻之徒》里拍了那11季，然后又是《熊家餐馆》，你每次去的时候都会找个新地方住，还是说你有一个固定的落脚点？真是个好问题，肖恩？
That's great. Thank you. What part of Shikonk? Who's your broker? So we shot most of shameless in L.A. But we'd go for like a week at a time. Oh, I got it. Okay, got it.
太棒了。谢谢。芝加哥的哪个区？谁是你的房产经纪人？我们在洛杉矶拍了大部分的《无耻之徒》。但我们每次会去那儿待上一周左右。哦，我明白了。好的，明白了。
So we'd stay in a hotel. I thought you shot the whole thing there. No, no, no. Yeah, no. First week in showbiz. We do. We're catching. We're catching.
所以我们会住在酒店里。我还以为你整部剧都在那儿拍的呢。不，不，不。对，没错。演艺圈的第一周。我们确实在拍。我们在拍。
We do shoot all of the bear in Chicago, and we stay all in the same place, and it's great, because all of us are, like, on the same floor, and we all cook together and eat together. Oh, that's great. Is breakfast included? Yeah, exactly, yeah. Right, right.
我们确实把《熊家餐馆》的所有戏份都在芝加哥拍摄，而且我们都住在同一个地方，这太棒了，因为我们所有人都住在同一层楼，大家一起做饭、一起吃饭。哦，那太棒了。含早餐吗？对，没错，对。对，对。
Okay, wow. But, yeah. So Apollo 13, the movie, they didn't film that in space, then, no? A portion of it. Okay, so you get the bear. So now you start doing the bear. So you come out of this, by the way, Sean, I was going to ask you,
好的，哇。但是，是的。所以《阿波罗13号》那部电影，他们不是在太空里拍摄的，对吧？一部分是。好吧，所以你得到了《熊家餐馆》的角色。然后你开始拍《熊家餐馆》。所以你从这之中走出来——顺便说一句，肖恩，我正想问你，
you also had that thing with like Will and Grace, how long was that on the air? Yeah, how long? Total 11 seasons, but broken up to 8 and 3. So did you feel when that was over? Yeah. Well, you know, I try to be self-aware. I'm sure these guys did too during Rest Development
你以前也演过《威尔和格蕾丝》，那部剧播了多久？对，多久？总共11季，但分成了8季和3季。所以当它结束时，你有那种感觉吗？有。嗯，你知道的，我尽量保持自我觉察。我相信这些人在《发展受阻》期间也是这样的，
that you know when something's working and you have a gig and you have job security and somewhere to go every day and hopefully every year with each season that you start trying to think ahead. Like, okay, I'm self-aware enough to know that this is working now, I have to use this to get another gig.
你知道当某部剧反响不错，你有一份工作和职业保障，每天都有地方可去，并且希望每年随着每一季的播出都有着落时，你就会开始未雨绸缪。比如，好吧，我有足够的自我觉察能力，知道这现在行得通，我必须利用这一点来获得下一份工作。
I have to make sure I can parlay this into another gig. And as hard as you try, you just can't, like Jason always says, you can't control it. You can't control, you know, where your career goes. You can try, but it's like, you know, just kind of do your part. You do have to let go. Yeah.
我必须确保我能把这转化成另一份工作。不管你多么努力，你就是无法控制——正如杰森总是说的那样，你无法控制。你无法控制，你知道的，你的职业生涯会走向何方。你可以去争取，但这就好像是，你知道的，做好你自己的本分。你确实得学会放手。对。
We never, well, certainly unarrested, we never had. How long was arrested? The first incarnation was three years. Oh, right, but then you guys came back. We never had job security, even when, after we went. won the Emmy, we were on the verge of being canceled the next week. That's so crazy. It's such a
我们从来没有——好吧，在《发展受阻》剧组肯定没有。那部剧播了多久？最初的第一阶段是三年。哦，对，但后来你们又回归了。我们从来没有过职业安全感，甚至在我们赢得艾美奖之后，第二周我们就面临着被砍的边缘。这太疯狂了。那可是一部
great show. That's unbelievable. Every time we go past the guard shack at studio, we'd wonder if there'd still be a drive on for us. But you guys knew how good it was. You guys could all feel how good it was, right? I mean, it's like a boring question. But it was like, but we were all a bunch of weirdos on that show. We're like, well,
非常棒的剧。这简直难以置信。每次我们走过制片厂的门卫室时，我们都会琢磨里面是不是还给我们留着车位。但你们当时明明知道它有多好。你们所有人都感受得到它有多好，对吧？我的意思是，这好像是个挺无聊的问题。但这就像是，我们当时在这部剧里都是一群怪咖。我们在想，好吧，
is this going to translate? Are other people going to think this is funny? Yes, we never knew. I never had, I never had that job security. I never had like a long term job in that way. Right. And yet you work more than literally anybody, I know. I don't know if that's true, but it's weird.
这能引起共鸣吗？其他人会觉得这好笑吗？是的，我们从来不知道。我从来没有，我从来没有过那种职业安全感。我从来没有过那种长期的工作。对。然而你工作量之大，简直超过了我认识的任何人。我不知道这算不算真的，但挺奇怪的。
You're doing okay, Will. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. So you get that, so now you come off that and then all of a sudden you find yourself you're shooting the pilot and then the show gets picked up and could you have predicted that the bear would make, would resonate with fans and critics and everybody as much as it did when you were doing it?
你现在过得挺好，威尔。对。谢谢。谢谢。所以你拿到了那个角色，然后你拍完了，突然之间你发现自己在拍试播集，接着这部剧被预订了，你在拍摄的时候能预料到《熊家餐馆》会像后来那样在粉丝、评论家和所有人中引起如此大的共鸣吗？
even more so than shameless. Yeah. Yeah, no, I mean, you know, I think all of you guys know that the feeling of kind of making something and knowing that it feels exciting and fresh and that you love all the other actors and everybody's doing such great work. But then, you know, that almost doesn't matter, you know, you put something out and will it connect or will anybody watch? It's just a whole other thing. So I think we all knew how exciting it was to make and we all hope. hoped we could do more. But I think my greatest hope for the show when we were shooting the first season
甚至比《无耻之徒》还要轰动。对。是的，不，我的意思是，你知道的，我想你们所有人都知道那种感觉：创作了一些东西，并且知道它让人感到兴奋和新鲜，你爱剧组的所有其他演员，每个人都在做着如此棒的工作。但随后，你知道的，那几乎不重要，你知道的，你把作品推向市场，它会引起共鸣吗？还是会有人看？这完全是另一回事。所以我想我们都知道创作它是多么令人兴奋，我们也希望。希望我们能拍更多。但我觉得我们在拍摄第一季时对这部剧最大的期望
was like maybe we can find kind of like a niche sort of like market where like people in service really dig this show or like, you know, like it's like respected by, I think that was the goal is like will kitchens like this show, will back of house like this show, does this seem real? So the fact that it connected with as many people as it did and was watched as much.
就是：也许我们可以找到某种小众市场，比如餐饮服务业的人真的很喜欢这部剧，或者，你知道的，它能受到尊重——我想当时的目标就是：厨房里的从业人员会喜欢这部剧吗？前厅和后厨的人会喜欢这部剧吗？这看起来真实吗？所以，它能与这么多人产生共鸣并且有那么高的收看量，
as it has been was definitely a surprise yeah and you're on year what you're on year four of the bear we will start shooting five next year wow yeah yeah how many episodes of season it changes it's sometimes it's eight sometimes it's 10 but it's always right around there yeah that's great and now you're a great big movie star on top of it all too like how you's gonna stuff it all in bud oh man what I feel like I want to take a take a nap I don't know
绝对是个惊喜，对。你现在是在拍第几季？你在拍《熊家餐馆》的第四季，我们明年将开始拍摄第五季。哇。对，对。一季有多少集？会有所改变，有时是8集，有时是10集，但总是差不多这个数。对，太棒了。现在你除此之外还是个超级大电影明星，像你这样——怎么把所有这些都塞进日程里呢，老兄？哦，天哪。我觉得我想去小睡一会儿。我不知道。
I'm very like I'm excited to go do the you know the next season of the show and then I'm like I mean it's been so lovely what the show has given me but I'm definitely I definitely want to like hang out at home and take the kids to school and stuff yeah because it does seem like those things
我非常——我很兴奋去拍，你知道的，下一季的剧集，然后我就觉得——我的意思是，这部剧带给我的东西太美好了，但我绝对——我绝对想去家里待着，带孩子们去上学之类的，对，因为确实感觉那些事情——
there are people that are uniquely suited to like constantly be in a public position and sort of do that whole thing. Away from home and all that stuff. Yeah, it's hard. Yeah, that really like to be at home, that are sort of private, that are sort of shy,
有些人天生就适合一直处于公众视线中，去应付那一整套流程。远离家乡以及所有那些事情。是的，这很难。是的，真的很想待在家里，比较注重隐私，有点害羞的人，
that it's sort of antithetical to the whole public job, right? And you do seem to be someone that enjoys, like me, I think all three of us, who kind of enjoy being kind of nesters. Yeah, trying to find a bit of a routine or a little bit of, like, I don't know. rhythm you know i i get very thrown and when you go out you feel like you got to like kind of throw the switch a little bit and kind of okay now we got to kind of do this a bit but it kind of
这和整个公开抛头露面的工作简直是背道而驰，对吧？而你似乎正是那种享受——像我一样，我觉得我们三个都是——有点享受当“御宅族”的人。对，试图寻找一点规律，或者一点，我不知道，节奏。你知道的，我——我很容易被打乱阵脚，当你出门时，你会觉得自己必须得切换一下状态，然后，好吧，现在我们得装模作样地应付一下，但它渐渐地
becomes a part of you is that is it become a comfortable part of you which part like just like flying around and yeah and doing the thing and and and and promoting stuff and everybody's like looking at you and going like being a public figure there's jeremy you know i mean yeah i don't know i mean i don't think that i'll ever feel for me like a comfortable thing but i think you can get better at sort of like hiding your anxiety perhaps yeah for sure you know what you know what's funny jeremy like this weekend actually at one point i was on somewhere on social media and a photo came up and if you have in our friend uh jamie who we just mentioned yeah uh and and it and it was like seen with unidentified and i was like there we go you're there with jamie who you work with yes
成了你的一部分，它成了你习惯的一部分吗？哪一部分？就像四处飞来飞去，以及做那些事，宣传各种东西，每个人都看着你，说——作为公众人物，那是杰里米，你知道的，我的意思是。我不知道，我的意思是，我不认为对我来说这会变成一件舒服的事，但我认为你可以更好地去隐藏你的焦虑，也许吧。对，肯定的。你知道的，你知道什么是搞笑的吗，杰里米？这个周末其实有那么一刻，我在社交媒体上的某处看到了一张照片，照片里有我们的朋友——我们刚才提到过的杰米，对，然后上面写着“与未知名人士一同被拍”，当时我就想：原来在这儿呢，你和与你共事的杰米在一起，是的。
and then and then people sort of glob you know sort of lobbing comments and saying like who's this person Who's the person? Who's the person? And you're just like, hey, man, the guy's out where he's working or he's doing this and he's in the city. Like, it's just, and that part is bizarre, right? It's just, it never gets really normal. Are you able to see that as kind of fun and funny? Yeah, I mean, you know, I love Jamie and I've known her for so long.
然后人们就开始——你知道的，开始抛出评论说：“这人是谁？”“这人是谁？”“这人是谁？”而你就会觉得：嘿，老兄，这家伙要么是在工作，要么在做这个，而且他在城里。就像是，这部分真的很离谱，对吧？这从来不会真正变得正常。你能把这看作是有趣好玩的事吗？是的，我的意思是，你知道的，我爱杰米，我认识她很久了。
So, like, that kind of thing is funny. And that's what I get for, you know, whatever, staying at the Bowery. But I just, but no, that stuff is, yeah, it's like, it's like, it's, strange you certainly don't get used to it like i i have this farmer's market i i love to go to and i've gone to for you know six seven years that's very close to my house and i go every sunday and and i feel like that thing that was mine or me and my daughters or like whatever that very like private kind of like nice routine has kind of been yeah like spoiled by that sort of uh the attention so so yeah when those things happen i mean i understand it comes with you know i'm i'm very lucky to
所以，这种事挺搞笑的。这就是我留在鲍里酒店（Bowery）的代价，不管怎样。但我只是——不，这些事情，是的，这就像是，这很奇怪。你绝对无法习惯它。比如我有一个非常喜欢的农夫市集，我已经去了六七年了，离我家非常近，我每个星期天都会去。我觉得那个属于我的、或者属于我和我女儿们的地方——或者不管怎样，那种非常私人的、美好的日常——有点被这种……注意力给毁了。所以，是的，当这些事情发生时，我的意思是，我知道这随之而来，你知道的——我很幸运能
be working in this career that I've wanted to be in for so long and have these opportunities and this is something that comes with it. But yeah, none of it is normal, you know, none of it feels normal. Do you talk to your kids about it? Like, do you explain, try to explain it to them? Are they old enough yet? Yeah, I mean, I just try to explain it as like people get excited, you know, they know I'm on television and they'll see like posters and things and, you know, I explain that people get excited about kind of thinking they understand a version of your dad,
从事我一直想从事的职业，拥有这些机会，而这也是随之而来的代价。但是，没有什么是正常的，你知道的，没有任何事感觉是正常的。你会和你的孩子们谈论这件事吗？比如，你会向他们解释、试着向他们解释吗？他们年龄够大了吗？对，我的意思是，我只是试着向他们解释说，人们会感到兴奋，你知道的，他们知道我在电视上，他们会看到海报之类的东西，然后，你知道的，我解释说人们会因为觉得自己理解了你爸爸的某一面而感到兴奋，
but it's not really your dad. And I'm, you know, you know me and these people don't really know me, but they get excited because they see this version of me. But Ezzie, my oldest spots people quicker than I do. She's got like a real like hawk eye
但那并不是真正的爸爸。而且我——你知道的，你们了解我，这些人并不真正了解我，但他们感到兴奋是因为他们看到了我这一面。不过Esi，我大女儿，认人的速度比我还快。她对人有着一双真正像鹰眼一样的眼睛。
for people. When someone pretends to be going through their emails. Put it up their phone or doing a double take. be like, we better keep moving. That's great. And she's seven? So it's nice that she's sharp. Yeah, I'm glad that she's, you know.
当有人假装在看电子邮件时。掏出手机或者回头再看一眼。她就会说：“我们最好还是继续走吧。”太棒了。她才七岁？所以她这么机灵挺好的。对，我很高兴她能，你知道的。
I was with somebody once, and somebody was taking like a sneaky pick of them, and then came up and said, can I get a pick? And they said, you already got it. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Respect, you know, respect. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
我有一次跟一个人在一起，有人偷拍了他们一张照片，然后那个人走过来问：“我能合个影吗？”结果那人回答：“你们已经拍过了。”对。对，对，对。表示尊重，你知道的，给予尊重。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。
J.B., what have you, have you ever, what do you say to your girls? your girls are older now but did you say back in the day have that convo with them i made a mistake early on of um we know but i want to know about this um i remember once we were driving past a poster and uh and and one of my daughters said oh we were driving to school and she's like oh i can't wait to tell my friends that you know you're on a poster and i my instinct was i said no no no you can't you can't do don't ever say and i kind of because i didn't want her to be you know bragging or like Right, right, right. I try, I overcompensated and kind of made it.
JB，你经历过什么，你对你的女儿们说过什么？你的女儿们现在长大了，但你以前跟她们有过那种对话吗？我早期犯过一个错误，就是……我们懂的，但我很想知道这个……我记得有一次我们开车路过一张海报，然后——我的一个女儿说——哦，我们在开车去学校，她说：“哦，我等不及要告诉我的朋友们，你知道的，你在海报上。”我的第一直觉是说：“不，不，不，你不能，你不能这样做，绝对不要说。”我有点——因为我不想让她（显得）——你知道的——炫耀，或者像——对，对，对。我试图——我矫枉过正了，把它弄得——
Right, it landed in a way that was like panicked about. Right, that you should hide the fact of what your dad does. Like they almost thought that what I did was a bad thing. Right, right. And so I kind of had to undo that. But, you know, what do I, I never had kids before his first for me. I mean, how old were, when was, yeah, how did you guys handle that kind of stuff, you and Amanda?
对，结果给人的感觉好像是——对这事感到恐慌。对，就好像你应该隐瞒你爸爸是做什么的这个事实。她们甚至觉得我做的事是一件坏事。对，对。所以我不得不去纠正这一点。但是，你知道的，我能怎么办？我以前又没当过爸爸，这是我的第一次。我的意思是，你当时多大——当——对，你们是怎么处理那种事情的，你和阿曼达？
It's, you know, you just, you try to keep an eye on, like, when's the first possible moment they can understand the smart version of this conversation. Right. You know, and try to have it then as opposed to the dumb version of the conversations, which is what I had. And it's just sort of just like, you know, a big dull, you know, dumb, blunt instrument, you know, saying, no, this is bad. Don't talk about it.
这，你知道的，你只能——你试着留意，比如——什么时候才是她们能理解这种对话的理智版本的第一个可能时机？对，你知道的，然后试着在那时进行对话，而不是去进行那些愚蠢版本的对话——那就是我曾经做过的。那简直就像是一个又大又沉闷、愚蠢而粗暴的工具，你知道的，说着：“不，这不好。不要谈论这个。”
This is, you know, over here is good. And it just was kind of stupid. So I just kind of kicked the can down the road for a bit, I guess. Jeremy, what's your dream role? Great, great, great. I want to hear this. Yeah, I know this is great. One more thing on Chicago.
这个，你知道的，那边那个才是好的。这简直有点蠢。所以我大概只是把问题往后拖了一阵子吧，我想。杰里米，你梦想中的角色是什么？太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。我很想听听这个。对，我知道这太棒了。关于芝加哥还有最后一件事。
So what was the commute like from the place you guys were staying? Well, Sean, I will. I mean, do you go back a lot? Like, do you have a restaurant I should be going to that I don't know about? Like, what's going on? Yeah, I love that. Jeremy, okay, go ahead. I love the R.L. restaurant, the Ralph Lauren Polo restaurant.
所以你们住的地方通勤是怎样的？好吧，肖恩，我当然会。我的意思是，你经常回去吗？比如，有什么我不知道但应该去光顾的餐厅吗？到底是怎么回事？对，我喜欢这样。杰里米，好的，请说。我喜欢R.L.餐厅，也就是拉夫·劳伦马球餐厅（Ralph Lauren Polo restaurant）。
Of course. It's the best. Come on, really? We can all walk. It's the best. For lunch, we're there. Chris Dor, the creator of the creator of the restaurant. the Bears there every, every day.
当然。那是最好的。拜托，真的吗？我们都可以步行去。那是最好的。午餐时间，我们就去那儿。克里斯·斯托勒——这家餐厅的创作者——熊家餐馆的创作者，每天都在那儿。
And it's attached to the Ralph Lauren store. So you just go shopping. I believe it's Ralph Lauren. You know what? The one in Paris is very good too. It's actually, really, really good. But Jared, like, is there, because you have so much going on and you have to balance, you know, like you said, be nice to take my kids to school or whatever, is there something that's coming up or something that you've always wanted to do where you're just like, God, I really need to do that, I really want to do that, I have to get this.
而且它和拉夫·劳伦专卖店连在一起。所以你吃完就能直接去购物。我想那是拉夫·劳伦的。你知道吗？巴黎的那家也非常不错。实际上真的、真的很棒。但是杰里米，就像是——因为你手头有太多事要忙，你得平衡，你知道的，就像你说的，去接我孩子们放学之类的，有没有什么即将到来的事情，或者你一直想做但心想：“天哪，我真的很需要做那个，我真的很想做，我必须得到这个”？
But I can't do it because of kids. Or I have to figure it out. I don't know. I mean, I don't think of, you know, I kind of take things as they come. Like you are like, I have to play Bruce Springsteen. It was more like a collaborative, hey, what do you think about this? Yeah, I mean, that came, yeah, Bruce came to me and the script came to me through Scott Cooper, who's a director I've, like, admired for really long time.
但我又因为孩子而做不了。或者我必须想办法解决它。我不知道。我的意思是，我不会去想——你知道的，我基本上是兵来将挡，水来土掩。比如你是那种——我必须扮演布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷。那更像是一种合作，嘿，你觉得这个怎么样？对，我的意思是，那是——布鲁斯找到了我，剧本是通过斯科特·库珀（Scott Cooper）来到我这里的，他是一位我钦佩了很久的导演。
Great filmmaking. And I think that's how I always move is sort of who are the directors, who are the writer. who are the producers, like, who are the actors I want to work with? So, like, the genre or the world, while those can be, like, very exciting things are almost secondary to, you know, I really want to work with Paulo Sorrentino, or I really, like, every actor wants to just do, like,
伟大的电影制作人。我想我一直以来做事的方式就是看导演是谁，编剧是谁，
a line in a Paul Thomas Anderson movie, you know, that's always kind of what I'm looking for. There's no sort of, like, archetype or world that I'm necessarily, like, I need to do this. Got it, got it, got it. Sean, what about you, something fun? What would you like to do right now? I'm serious that somebody said,
制片人是谁，演员是谁——我想和谁合作？所以，题材或世界观——虽然这些都可以是非常令人兴奋的事情——但它们几乎是次要的，（我更看重）我真的很想和保罗·索伦蒂诺合作，或者我真的——每个演员都只想在保罗·托马斯·安德森的电影里演一句台词，你知道的，那才是我一直在寻找的。并没有那种原型或者世界观是我一定觉得——我必须要拍这个。明白了，明白了，明白了。肖恩，你呢，有什么好玩的事？你现在最想做什么？我是说真的，如果有人对你说：
you can pick a genre right now, what would you do? I want to play, I told you, I want to play a complete fucking maniacal serial killer. Or someone who's just, you would never, ever expect me to play. Like, I want to play the super nice guy who is, you know, affable and kind of just, like, funny or whatever. And then he fucking rips people's necks apart when nobody's around. So that's his mode as he rips people's neck apart? That's right. I wrote it down.
“你现在可以挑一个题材，你想做什么？”我想演——我告诉过你，我想演一个彻头彻尾的精神病连环杀手。或者是一个你绝对、绝对想不到我会去演的角色。比如，我想演一个超级大好人，为人随和、善良、有点风趣或者诸如此类的。然后当没人的时候，他妈的把别人的脖子给撕裂。所以他的作案手法就是把别人的脖子撕裂？没错。我记下来了。
You want me to send it to you? Okay. Again. What kind of weapon would you, would your guy use, Sean? Just my hands. Wow. I've had a cake knife. How about think about it for a second?
你想让我发给你吗？好的。再来。你的角色会使用什么武器，肖恩？就用我的双手。哇。我用过蛋糕刀。要不考虑一下再回答？
Jesus, let me get the question. Just trying to cover up the motivation, let him finish the, just my hands. But no, you know, kind of like, you know like, you know like, you're like, you're like, who is this guy? Like, he can't. No, he wasn't, I mean, he worked all the time before that, but that was what made him famous. You're like, wow, that's such a cool, crazy...
天哪，让我把问题听完。只是想掩饰一下动机，让他把话说完——就用我的双手。但是不，你知道的，那种感觉——就像是，你知道的——你会想：这人是谁？他怎么可能——不，他以前一直在工作，但那正是让他成名的事情。你会觉得：哇，这真是太酷、太疯狂了……
Sean, do we need to go look into your garage? Is this something? Do we need to be searching? Everything's fine, everything's fine. Willie, what about you? Yeah. What's that? What about it, like a drink?
肖恩，我们需要去检查一下你的车库吗？这是怎么回事？我们需要搜查一下吗？一切都好，一切都好。威利，你呢？对。什么？那这个呢，像喝一杯？
You could rub the genie bottle. Next, next role, next part. It's a... Or it could be a genre. It's a newborn. The newborn. You'd like to be, you'd like to do some action work. Takeover, yeah, in the first scene, Maddie and I battle it out.
你可以擦一擦神灯。下一个角色，下一个部分。这是一个……或者可以是一个题材。一个新生儿。新生儿。你想要——你想要做一些动作戏。接管一切，对吧，在第一场戏里，马迪和我大打出手。
Sure. And then I, and with the silencer, I take him out. And you take his wallet and his identification. And I take his identification. And right before he does, Damon looks at me and goes, you're the best. And then I take over. Wow. But you haven't thought about it.
当然。然后我，用消音器，把他解决掉。然后你拿走了他的钱包和身份证。我拿走了他的身份证。就在他断气之前，达蒙看着我说：“你是最棒的。”然后我接管了一切。哇。但你还没考虑过呢。
Well, I want him to compliment me before, you know what I mean? His last words. Now, do you, but in all honesty, if somebody came to you with like a big-ass action, film right now, would you not think about the fact that the stunt work could be very challenging? I feel like that stuff's exciting to me.
好吧，我希望他在死前先夸夸我，你知道我的意思吗？他的遗言。现在，你——但说实话，如果有人现在带着一部大型动作电影来找你，你难道不会考虑到特技工作可能会非常具有挑战性吗？我觉得那些东西让我感到兴奋。
I mean, that all feels like that all feels like that. He's a young guy. He's not scared of that, Jason. No, what about you? Will, do you think you'd tell you, would you say yes to some stunt work? You'd blow out your fucking hammy coming out of your fucking dressing room. Coming out of your dressing room.
我的意思是，这一切都感觉像——这一切都感觉像——他是个年轻小伙子。他不怕那个，杰森。不，你呢？威尔，你觉得你会答应——你会答应做一些特技工作吗？你从更衣室出来的时候就会把你的臭大腿拉伤的。从更衣室出来的时候。
Oh! I'm out! I'm out! I'm out! I'm out! says you, JB would show up for his first stuff and they'd be like, you can't do this in slippers. But I think that, yeah, I would actually think more
哦！我不干了！我不干了！我不干了！我不干了！这话是你说的，JB去拍他的第一场特技戏时，剧组会说：“你不能穿着拖鞋拍这个。”但我认为，是的，我其实会更多地考虑
about the time that would take to be a way to do something like that and the first one would freak me out more than anything, to be honest. That's looking like six months, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I know, it is such a big factor in deciding, isn't it? Like, where am I going to be and for how long and what, yeah.
做那种事需要花掉的时间，要离开家去完成它，而且第一天会比什么都让我感到恐慌，说实话。那看起来得花上六个月的时间，对吧？对，对，对，对。我知道，这确实是决定时的一个重大因素，对吧？比如：我要去哪里？去多久？还有什么——对。
Yeah, and we all have, you know, we have kids and you have lives and stuff, and especially at our age, Jeremy, you're lucky that you're sort of young. You have all these kind of... But for me, I'm like, oh, God, I'm so tired. Yeah. You have a young one.
是的，我们都有，你知道的，我们有孩子，你们有各自的生活等等，尤其是到了我们这个年纪——杰里米，你很幸运，你还算年轻。你有所有这些——但对我来说，我就觉得：哦，天哪，我太累了。对。你还有一个年幼的孩子。
I do. I do. I have a five-year-old. I have a five-year-old and a 15-year-old and a 17-year-old. So these are like... You are tired. Yeah, I am tired. And these are...
我确实有。我确实有。我有一个五岁的孩子，还有一个15岁的和一个17岁的孩子。所以这些都是——你真的很累。对，我是真的很累。而且这些是——
Although my five-year-old slept through the night last night, which he hasn't been doing for a while, but he did last night, which was a big... Even though I look crazy exhausted right now. Is he sleep in bed with you? No, no. because that's a slippery slope but it is a slippery
虽然我五岁的孩子昨晚一觉睡到了天亮，他已经有一段时间没这样了，但他昨晚做到了，这真是一个重大的——尽管我现在的确看起来疲惫不堪。他是在你们床上睡觉吗？不，不。因为那是一条滑坡，但这确实是一个滑坡——
you know sometimes I'll go down and sort of get in and sort of calm him down and stuff like that if he wakes up in the night but yeah he's not a great sleeper but anyway
你知道的，有时我会下楼去，钻进被窝里，试图让他平静下来之类的，如果他夜里醒来。但是的，他不是个很能安睡的孩子，不过不管怎样，
we're getting you know hey listen it's cool I'm 55 hey um yeah can you can you oh is it Jare now
我们正在——你知道的，嘿，听着，这挺酷的，我55岁了。嘿，嗯——你能——哦，现在改叫Jare（杰尔）了吗？
yeah yeah sure why not I don't have the time do people call you Jared are you called Jare by your friends Jare yeah Jair bears, yeah. How about Jodog?
对，对，当然，为什么不呢。我没有时间。人们都叫你Jared，还是你的朋友们叫你Jare？Jare，对。Jare bears（杰尔熊），对。叫Jodog（乔狗）怎么样？
Yeah. Jodog is, yeah, a lot. No, truly? Yeah. Yeah. J. J.O. was in like middle school, high school. Jawbone.
对。Jodog这个，对，很多人叫。真的吗？对。对。J.O.是初中、高中时候的事了。Jawbone（下颌骨）。
On the bear set, jaw dog is around. This, I'm being genuine. I love it. Jaw dog. Yes, of course. Well, my initials, yeah, or J.W. Yeah, I got it. We can do the math.
在《熊家餐馆》片场，大家会叫我Jaw dog。我这是在说真的。我太喜欢了。Jaw dog。是的，当然。好吧，我的首字母，对，或者J.W.对，我明白了。我们可以做一下算术。
Okay. So listen, but when, Because I know what you mean. Sean, your hair is distracting. I'm getting it. Yeah, what time's the gig later on? You just cover all flock of seagulls and nothing else, right? No, I have a figure skating gig next little bit.
好吧。所以听着，但是当——因为我明白你的意思。肖恩，你的头发太让人分心了。我懂的。对，稍后的演出是几点？你只是去模仿海鸥合唱团（Flock of Seagulls）的造型，别的什么都不做，对吧？不，接下来我有一场花样滑冰的演出。
But, Jerr, do you have... Because I'm talking about the anxiety thing and stuff like that. Do you, can you, when you're not working and you have family, can you shut it off and not think about agents and lawyers? and deals and scripts and all that stuff, can you completely separate, or is it always kind of there? I think, yeah, I mean, that's, you know,
但是，杰尔，你有没有——因为我刚才在谈论焦虑之类的事情。你，当你没在工作并且和家人在一起时，你能把它关掉，不去想经纪人、律师、合约、剧本和所有那些事情吗？你能彻底把它们隔离开来，还是说它们总是萦绕在那里？我想，是的，我的意思是，那就是——
when I'm around, yeah, my kids, you're forced to just, you have to be completely present. It's like, so I guess that's, yeah, the second time I found kind of real peace or focus is, yeah, and having kids, everything just kind of like narrowed, and you're like, oh, this is it. This is, you know, this is where my attention is. This is where I want to be.
当我周围有——对，我的孩子们时，你被迫只能——你必须完全身处当下。这就像是，所以我想那就是——我第二次找到真正的平静或专注的时刻，就是有了孩子之后，一切都缩小了，你会觉得：哦，就是这个。这就是，你知道的，这就是我的注意力所在。这就是我想在的地方。
This is, you know. Right. And so, yeah, I'm able to do that when I'm home. Yeah, for sure. And when it's not kids, when it's not, what else are you, like, what is just you, what do you do to completely decompress? No work, no kids, something stupid, something settling. is there, what would we be surprised to learn
这就是，你知道的。对。所以，是的，我在家的时候能够做到这一点。绝对可以。当不是和孩子在一起时，当不是——你还在做别的什么，比如，纯粹是你自己时，你做些什么来彻底减压？没有工作，没有孩子，做点无聊的事，做点能让你安顿下来的事。有没有什么，我们会惊讶地发现
is your weird-ass hobby or your shitty TV show that you watch? I mean, I watch... Well, okay, so I'm obsessed with, like, reality, real estate shows. And I'm, like, always on my realtor at. I don't buy anything, but I like to fantasize about, like, buying stuff all the time.
你的古怪爱好或者你看的那些烂俗电视节目是什么？我的意思是，我看的——好吧，这么说吧，我迷上了——比如，真人秀房地产节目。我总是泡在房地产应用上。我不买任何东西，但我喜欢幻想自己一直在买东西。
That's why those shows are so popular. We do, too, the three of us do. I send listings to friends and they're like, just buy it then. Like, what do you want for me? And I'm like, no, I don't know, I don't know. Wait, so like those weird realtors? Million dollar listing.
这就是那些节目为什么这么受欢迎的原因。我们也是，我们三个都这样。我把房源信息发给朋友，他们会说：“那就买下来呗。你到底想从我这得到什么？”而我说：“不，我不知道，我不知道。”等等，就像那些古怪的房地产经纪人节目？《百万美元房产清单》。
Yeah, selling sunset or owning Manhattan just started up again. I'm very excited. My guy, Ryan Sirhan. Yeah, Brian Surhant is like incredible. Came from nothing and built an empire. I'm very impressed by that man. Easy.
对，《日落豪宅》（Selling Sunset）或者刚开播的《曼哈顿地产女王》（Owning Manhattan），我又开始看了，非常兴奋。我的偶像，瑞安·塞尔豪特（Ryan Serhant）。对，布赖恩·瑟汉特简直太不可思议了。白手起家，建立了自己的商业帝国。我对那个人印象非常深刻。Easy（太容易了）。
No, but I mean, it's cool. Yeah, but that's my. like I, you know, I just like look at stuff. If I'm visiting, like, I don't know, I'm like traveling for work or even like I like doing road trips. I don't know if I'm in a small town I think is really sweet. Instantly I'm kind of on like Zillow or the realtor app. And I'm like, what if I got another place here?
不，但我的意思是，这很酷。是的，但那就是我的——就像我，你知道的，我只是看看房子。如果我在访问——比如，我不知道，我因为工作在旅行，甚至就像我喜欢自驾游。我不知道，如果我在一个小镇觉得真的很可爱。我立刻就会打开Zillow或者房地产应用。然后我想：如果我在那儿也有个地方会怎么样？
What if I just like, you know, would come here all the time? What is it? I do the same thing. Wherever I go, I'm immediately thinking about getting a place there. Is it because that's how I could feel like at home there? Yeah, maybe. Yeah, maybe it's a way to try to, like, get some control over, I feel like a lot of it comes back to control for me. Exactly. I want to be a local immediately.
如果我只是——你知道的，经常来这儿会怎么样？那是什么心理？我也做过同样的事。无论我去哪里，我立刻就会考虑在那里置业。是因为这样能让我觉得在那里有家的感觉吗？对，也许吧。是的，也许这是一种试图——获得某种掌控感的方式，我觉得很多事情对我来说都归结于掌控欲。完全正确。我想立刻成为当地人。
What's the weirdest place that you ever, like, seriously concerned? Like, maybe I will get a place here. Was there ever one of those? Bisbee, Arizona. Wow. Really? I was really considering. Yeah, I did a road trip.
你去过的最奇怪的地方是什么，让你曾经认真考虑过——也许我应该在那里买个房？有过那样的地方吗？亚利桑那州的比斯比（Bisbee）。哇。真的吗？我当时真的在考虑。对，我进行了一次自驾游。
I've driven cross-country like four or five times, and I did one from L.A. to New York in December. This was like, I don't know, 10 years ago. And the first stop was Bisbee, Arizona, which is like a very small town. It looks kind of like Laurel Canyon. Like the buildings are very pastel colors, and it's kind of hilly. But it's in the middle of no. It's like desert, desert, desert, very small town, but very sweet. And I spent the night there and a bed and breakfast.
我横穿过四五次美国，其中有一次是在12月份从洛杉矶开到纽约。大概是，我不知道，10年前吧。我们的第一站是亚利桑那州的比斯比，那是一个非常小的镇。有点像劳雷尔峡谷。建筑是那种很淡的颜色，还有点丘陵。但它周围什么也没有。到处都是沙漠，非常小的镇，但很温馨。我在那里的一家民宿过了一夜。
Got up the next day, was like walking around, talking to locals. And everybody I spoke to, like nobody was from Bisby. Everybody was just passing through. and then they opened a sandwich shop or they opened a clothing store and it started to feel a little like twilight episode-y where I was like, oh, maybe this is one of those towns
第二天起床后，在街上溜达，跟当地人聊天。我遇到的每一个人，没有一个是比斯比本地人。大家都是路过，然后在那儿开了家三明治店或服装店，这让我开始觉得有点像《阴阳魔界》里的情节，当时我在想，哦，也许这就是那种镇子——
you stop in and you just, you can't get out of and I did get out, but then for about six months I was considering getting like a little house in Bisbee Arizona. What about these drives across country? Did you, did you ever have a big run in with a cop? Do you like to speed?
你开到这儿，然后就再也离不开了。不过我的确离开了，但大概有六个月的时间，我一直在考虑在亚利桑那州比斯比买个小房子。你们横穿全国的这些自驾游呢？你有没有跟警察起过什么大冲突？你喜欢超速吗？
I didn't, I'm really responsible on the road. You are? So you do the speed limit across the country? I go 10 above the speed limit. Okay. Yeah, it's what you set the cruise control. They won't have you. I just keep going at 10, yeah.
我没有，我在路上特别守规矩。是吗？所以你在全国开车都严格遵守限速？我比限速快10英里。好吧。对，你把定速巡航设在那里。他们不会找你麻烦。我一直保持超速10英里开，对。
But I did get a flat in St. George when I was driving cross-country a couple years ago. In the middle of the night, there was no one around. I didn't have cell service, and that was spooky. That's the worst. And then I finally got a cop stopped, and I got a spare. and I was going to spend the night in Vegas I was on my way back to LA but there was like a fight night
不过几年前我横穿全国时，在圣乔治车胎爆了。大半夜的，四周一个人也没有。我手机没有信号，这可真够吓人的。那感觉最糟糕了。后来总算拦住了一个警察，换了备胎。本来我打算在拉斯维加斯过夜的，我当时正赶回洛杉矶，但那天晚上有拳击赛，
and everything was booked everything I'm talking like holiday ins were booked all the nice hotels were booked eventually I got a hotel room was like the only hotel room left in Las Vegas but it was like $2,000 for the night it had a bowling out
结果到处都客满。我是说连假日酒店都客满了，所有好酒店都客满了。最后我弄到了一间酒店房间，是拉斯维加斯仅剩的一间房，但一晚要2000美元，里面居然还有一个保龄球——
it was like so absurd so I spent $2,000 to like lie down at 2 a.m and then pretty much get up at 6 a.m. to go get a real tire put on the car. Right, because you just had a little pizza cutter back to L.A. I just needed to sleep. You just slept in your car. I should have.
简直荒谬至极。所以我花了2000美元，在凌晨2点躺下，然后差不多凌晨6点就得起床，去给车换个真正的轮胎。对，因为你开回洛杉矶时车上只有一个小小的备胎。我只是需要睡觉。你直接睡在车里就行了。我本该这样的。
I should have. That's what I'm here for. Oh, should. Yeah. Yeah. Another thing for you, the list for your time machine. I know what you mean about that real, like anytime Scotty and I go anywhere, we immediately go, I always ask them like, could you live here? Could you live here? Could you live there? And it's always a small point. Those are
我本该这样的。这就是我来这儿的原因。哦，本该。对。好吧。你的时光机愿望清单上又多了一项。我懂你说的那种真实感，任何时候我和斯科蒂去什么地方，我们都会立刻问，我总是问他们：你能在__这里生活吗？你能在这里生活吗？你能在那儿生活吗？这总是微不足道的一点。那些是
many like Dunkin franchises and stuff like that. Right? No, but like, it's always the same thing where I think I would go, I think the idea of living smaller in a quaint town like Bisbee or whatever is great. But then the reality is, I don't know, this New York or L.A. or Miami or Chicago, the city really keeps you kind of going and alive. Yeah, I'd feel too isolated, I think. Yeah, a little bit.
很多邓肯甜甜圈这样的连锁店之类的。对吧？不对，但情况总是这样：我觉得自己会去，我觉得在像比斯比这样的古朴小镇过那种小生活的主意挺棒的。但现实是，我不知道，纽约、洛杉矶、迈阿密或芝加哥，大城市真的能让你一直动起来，充满活力。对，我觉得那样会太孤立了。对，有点。
I need some big town, too. Well, you're, for two things are, A, Sean, that is that, Sean does do that because I know for a fact, Sean will go even further. He won't even just look at online. He'll go and look at property with a local realtor. For sure, 100%. He does it all the time. Oh, whoa.
我也需要大城市。好吧，你，有两点，第一，肖恩，就是说，肖恩确实会那样做，因为我很确定，肖恩甚至会做得更过火。他不仅会在网上看。他会亲自去找当地的房产经纪人看房。肯定的，百分之百。他经常这么干。哦，哇。
Yes. Commitment. But you bought and you'll pull the trigger. No, God, no. No, no, no, no. He's wasting so many realtors' time. It's not even funny. He's like, persona and on a real whale.
是的。真投入。但你买了吗，你会痛快买下吗？不，天哪，不。不，不，不，不。他浪费了那么多房产经纪人的时间，简直搞笑。他就像是个伪装的大买家。
Yeah. But the other thing is I've noticed, sorry, go ahead, Sean. No, I just skip with that idea, Jeremy, the idea, like, do you come from a small town, and you prefer cities now? No, I grew up in Brooklyn. You're at the start of the show, right? I know, but Brooklyn isn't like a, like, you know, Brooklyn's city like, so do you prefer the opposite of that as you get older
对。但还有一件事我注意到，抱歉，你继续，肖恩。不，我只是顺着那个思路，杰里米，那个想法，比如，你是从小镇出来的，现在更喜欢城市吗？不，我在布鲁克林长大的。你刚开场时就说了吧？我知道，但布鲁克林可不是那种，你知道的，布鲁克林是个大城市，所以随着年龄增长，你反而更喜欢相反的环境吗？
because you didn't grow up that way? Maybe, I mean, yeah, I definitely like the idea of maybe one day having a place that's more slow moving and I have a, you know, a smaller place in L.A. Or if I'm back in New York, I have an apartment in the city, go upstate or Long Island or something like that. You ever see yourself getting
因为你小时候不是那样长大的？也许吧，我是说，对，我绝对喜欢这种想法：也许有一天能有个节奏更慢的地方，我在洛杉矶有一个小一点的住所。或者如果我回纽约，我在城里有一套公寓，然后去北部郊区、长岛或者类似的地方。你会不会觉得自己以后会
like a bunch of land and being like one of those guys with a bunch of like ranch, ranch tools and Kevin Costas. Again, like the fantasy of it. Yeah, I think. A bunch of props. What is it Jason's stuff
买一大片地，变成那种拿着一堆牧场工具、像凯文·科斯特纳一样的人？再次说明，这只是个幻想。对，我觉得。一堆道具。道具部门塞给你的都是些什么？杰森的那些东西吗？
that the prop department hands you? Yeah. You know, one of those cap guns. You're holding it upside down, Mr. Bateman. I'd be so useless. I think for a week it could be fun. Yeah, yeah. I hear you.
道具部门塞给你的？对。你知道，就是那种玩具枪。你把它拿倒了，巴特曼先生。那我可太没用了。我觉得玩一个星期可能会挺有意思的。对，对。我懂你的意思。
fantasy of it, but very quickly I'd realize there's no... I could see you upstate. I could see you upstate or on Long Island. Yeah, I have some friends that are up there and it's, and you know, I think it's sweet and then and then, yeah, Long Island I think is really nice and I rented a place last
幻想是挺好，但很快我就会意识到没有……我能想象你在北部郊区。我能想象你在北部郊区或者长岛。对，我有一些朋友在那边，我觉得挺惬意的，然后，然后，对，长岛我觉得真的很好，我去年夏天在那里租了个地方，
summer there that I really loved and and, and yeah, and all my people, my folks are still in Brooklyn, my sisters in Brooklyn. Oh, yeah, that's great. So I like going back there and being close. Well, personally I'd like you stay here in Los Angeles. Did you see each other? It is nice.
我真的很喜欢，而且，而且，对，我所有的人，我的家人都还在布鲁克林，我姐姐在布鲁克林。哦，对，那太好了。所以我喜欢回那边去，离他们近一点。嗯，就我个人而言，我希望你留在洛杉矶。你们最近见过吗？这挺好的。
What was the last movie? What was the last movie night? It's been a while. I mean, I'm still watching them. Yeah. But the door is still unlocked, a jar even, waiting for you people to come back. Fucking less creepy would be great.
最近看的什么电影？上次电影之夜是什么时候？已经有一段时间了。我是说，我还在看电影。对。不过大门依然开着，甚至虚掩着，等着你们这群人回来。要是听起来没那么诡异就更好了。
Just a little less creepy would be nice. That's the name of my autobiography. The door's a jar. The door is a jar. Gross. That's disgusting. God, it's so gross. Jimmy Allen, you are the man, man, man.
要是稍微没那么诡异就好了。这就是我的自传的名字：《门虚掩着》。门是虚掩的。真恶心。太恶心了。天哪，太恶心了。吉米·艾伦，你真是个爷们儿，太棒了。
I appreciate you. I appreciate you. It's just incredible. It's so well-deserved. You've worked hard for it, and you've been just consistently great all the way along. So we're big, big fans. I speak for Sean. Jason has his own take on it, which is a little more lascivious.
我很感激你。我很感激你。这简直不可思议。这是你应得的。你为之付出了努力，而且一路走来始终如一地优秀。所以我们都是你的超级粉丝。我代表肖恩说这话。杰森有他自己的看法，稍微有点色情。
No, I'm not there yet. Okay. I'm working on him. I'm trying to play hard to get. Love you, Jeremy, get over here again. This is a pleasure. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Nice to be tuned.
不，我还没到那份上。好吧。我正在说服他。我正试图摆出高姿态呢。爱你的，杰里米，再过来坐坐。太荣幸了。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。很高兴能连线。
Thanks for doing this, buddy. Be good, you guys. You're the best. See you, see you, see you. Will, did you get that full plate of food done? I know. First of all, he said, you're the best, and he was looking at me. Do you see that?
谢谢你做这些，老兄。你们好好的。你们是最棒的。再见，再见，再见。威尔，你那盘满满的食物吃完了吗？我知道。首先，他说“你们是最棒的”，然后他看着我。你看到了吗？
No, he was looking at my box. He was looking at me. You got a full plate of food delivered to you at the beginning of interview. Did you get it all done? What is it? It was like a chicken salad or something. Like a chicken salad. Oh, it was chicken salad.
不，他看着我的盒子。他看着我呢。采访刚开始时，有人给你送来了一大盘食物。你都吃完了吗？那是什么？好像是鸡肉沙拉什么的。就像鸡肉沙拉。哦，那是鸡肉沙拉。
Yeah. And who was that? It would seem like somebody was on their hands and knees down there at the door opening. She didn't want to interrupt. She didn't want to interrupt. It was Carolyn? That was Carolyn on her hands and knees?
对。那是谁呀？好像有人在那边门口跪着开门来着。她不想打扰。她不想打扰。那是卡洛琳吗？那是卡洛琳跪在地上吗？
She wasn't on her hands and knees. She bent down to put it at the door because she didn't want to interrupt. She was being very respectful. She should have come in. I love her. I know. I love her.
她没有跪在地上。她弯腰把它放在门口，因为她不想打扰。她表现得非常尊重。她本该进来的。我爱她。我知道。我爱她。
Don't you mess that up, Will. Oh, my God. Jesus. If it starts to get wobbly, you just hand it over and let us fix it, and then we'll give it back. Yeah. That's how relationships work, right? Yeah, sure.
威尔，你可别把事情搞砸了。哦，天哪。天哪。如果事情开始变得摇摇晃晃，你就把它交给我们来修，然后再还给你。对。这就是人际关系运作的方式，对吧？对，当然。
That's exactly how it works. You're handed over? Oh my God, I'm out of milk. Sean, is this the same Snickerdoodle? Yeah, he just killed it. It was really big. The last bite. Good boy. No, there's some more left him.
完全是这样的。你把它交出来了？哦天哪，我没牛奶了。肖恩，这是刚才那个士力架曲奇吗？对，他刚刚把它吃光了。真的很大一个。最后一口。好孩子。不，还剩一些给他。
Well, I'm really fond of... Oh, he's just the greatest. He's such a nice guy. I've only met him a couple of times. He's so nice. He's a good, normal person. He's really great. It would have been great up there on that stage. Are we going to reschedule that?
嗯，我真的很喜欢……哦，他太棒了。他是个很好的人。我只见过他几次。他太棒了。他是一个优秀、正常的人。他真的太棒了。能在那个舞台上一定很棒。我们还要重新安排那个活动吗？
Are we going to do the bowl, maybe, like, in the spring or something like that, maybe? Let's make a commitment that we're going to do something. Spring, summer, something like that. Let's for sure do it when it's not rainy season. We can't do it in the summer because they do the Philharmonic there in the summer. Every night? Most of it's programmed.
我们可能会把露天剧场演出改到春天或者什么时候办吗？我们定个承诺，一定要办一场。春天、夏天，诸如此类的。我们一定要挑不是雨季的时候办。夏天不行，因为他们夏天在那儿办爱乐乐团演出。每天晚上？大部分时间都排满了。
Why can't you do it over the summer? What about the beginning? L.A. Phil's in there through the summer. Are you like one night? Like September or like October before the rain starts. No, I don't argue with me. I'm happy to do it at any point. I think it's all about the guess.
为什么夏天不能办？那刚入夏的时候呢？洛杉矶爱乐乐团整个夏天都在那儿演出。就办一个晚上？比如9月或者10月，在下雨之前。不，别跟我争。我随时都可以办。我觉得关键在于嘉宾。
When can we get guests in there? You know, we've got to get some big shot guests because we're not cutting it, okay? People aren't coming out to see us blather on sitting on a couch. They want to see the stars. Wait, how did you and Jeremy meet again? A grinder. Oh, wow.
我们什么时候能请到大牌嘉宾？因为我们现在不够分量，好吧？人们才不会专门跑来看我们在沙发上废话连篇。他们想看大明星。等等，你和杰里米是怎么认识的来着？通过Grindr软件。哦，哇。
Wow. He's so candid about it. J.B., I didn't know this. Sean didn't want to say it because he's embarrassed because the same guy created the bear. Sean is about to do, they're doing a spin-off. He's doing the Cub. It's a different show.
哇。他真坦诚。杰·B，我不知道这事。肖恩刚才不想说，因为他觉得尴尬，因为创造《熊家餐馆》的是同一个人。肖恩正准备拍，他们正在拍一个衍生剧。他要拍《小熊》。是个不同的节目。
It's a different... It's a different... It's on YouTube or it's on porn tube or whatever. But whatever, it doesn't matter. Hey, listen, it sounds fun. By the way, when I saw the title of the bear, I was like, I'm in, click. Oh, it's about a restaurant.
是个不同的……是个不同的……它在YouTube上播，还是在色情网站上播，随便吧。但不管怎样，无所谓。嘿，听着，听起来挺有意思的。顺便说一句，当我看到《熊家餐馆》这个名字时，我想：我看了，点进去。哦，原来是讲餐厅的。
Mim, man, yeah, click on. People talking about food. Wait, is Grindr, is Grindr the hetero one or the gay one? Nice try. Which one? Say it, listen, oh, yeah. Hey, I'm confused. I don't believe a word.
人，天哪，对，点进去。人们在谈论食物。等等，Grindr是那个直男用的还是同性恋用的软件？好问题。哪个？说出来，听着，哦，对了。嘿，我糊涂了。我一个字也不信。
Wait, what are you doing? I'm so confused. Hand to God on my kid's life. I don't, which is which is which? Which is what? What are you asking? Is it Tinder? One of them's the gay one.
等等，你在干什么？我太糊涂了。以我孩子的生命发誓。我不知道，哪个是哪个？哪个是什么？你在问什么？是Tinder吗？其中一个是同性恋用的。
Yeah, Grindr's the gay one. You're acting so nervous. You're acting so nervous. I just want to make sure they get that on. And he's like, and delete account. We're still recording. Wait, you know, when Jeremy was playing Bruce Springsteen. Oh boy, here we go.
对，Grindr是同性恋用的。你表现得太紧张了。你表现得太紧张了。我只是想确保他们把这段录下来。而他就像是在说：“并删除账户”。我们还在录音呢。等等，你知道的，当年杰里米在扮演布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷时。哦，天哪，来吧。
Jesus. There is a song that I wonder because I haven't seen it yet. I haven't seen the show yet. And I wonder. if he sang the song in the movie called Johnny Bye-bye. Do you know that song that... At least commit to it? No, I was just like...
天哪。有一首歌我很好奇，因为我还没看过。我还没看过这部剧。我很好奇。他在电影里有没有唱过那首叫《再见，约翰尼》的歌？你知道那首歌……至少投入一点？不，我只是觉得……
Go right. Bye. Bye, bye, bye, that's good. Bye. Smartless. Smart. Yes. Smartless.
选得好。再见。再见，再见，再见，这挺好。再见。Smartless。Smart。是的。Smartless。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbecue. Co., Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless由班尼特烧烤公司、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔贾夫百分之百有机手工制作。Smartless。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。